all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontas and ty guy not
murdered over the campfire travis what
is going on gentlemen we just got a
little family episode going next time
you introduce somebody that way you got
to give him context please for the love
of
seriously just contacts didn't kill
travis
anything could happen
anything can happen thursday yeah like
big bang theory anything can happen
thursday apparently
and that could honestly be how tonight
goes
because um we are joined by a friend of
the show
uh general regular guest we actually had
a good cadence going for a little while
but without any introduction teddy
late late notice here but we got you in
how you doing man
i'm doing well thank you for coming to
my ted talk
air grievances and help dysfunctional
guardians get through their uh
their destiny problem so i'm excited to
talk about destiny
nice
nice
with the family you already know what it
is you already know what it is and then
we got the amazing not murdered travis
please again stop stop with that
the comments
the comedies
literally broke some rule by saying
murdered
but anyway
[Laughter]
i'm doing well i'm very not murdered
this week um it's uh
i've been i've been working on a game
review for ign for the past uh just a
little over a week called the rift
breaker which is one of the most um
sphincter clenching games i've played in
a long time it's uh
it's quite uh quite stressful and i had
to play it for 50 hours straight with
basically no breaks so wow that review
is live on ign.com right now you can
watch that i think i'll be on youtube
soon um and then i'm off to my next
review which is uh writer's republic the
ubisoft
obviously the free trial is going on
obviously right now yes the it's called
the trial week and you get to play for
four hours unless you're me then you get
to play as long as you want what up um
and obviously i'm uniquely qualified
because i was you know in the x games or
something um
but i do like sports games so i'm
excited absolutely
yeah so yeah it's been it's been a busy
review a couple weeks for me uh how
about you e how you feeling these days
uh well today was an interesting
absolute trash fire of a twitter world
so we'll get to that here in a little
while so yeah when you open that can of
worms
every so often they explode um but it's
been fun trying to get back into new
world a little bit still chopping trees
did my first dungeon last night even
though i got hard carried through thanks
to aries and uh clan that was in there
uh but yeah we've got you know still
been working on like the solo flawless
legend difficulty things which we will
also touch on those were
something um but she said you actually
like sports games actually i don't know
if you're really new that what or
something yeah
games that you've like kind of played
over the years any certain genres that
you like or
what's up oh yeah um
i'm like a big fifa guy uh yeah
that's the last time you get to call it
that i hear
yeah
that news has been crazy to me i've been
following that like obviously 2k is
super fun nba 2k if you guys have ever
played those games they're super
underrated
um
like you know i play lots of like the i
played like a lot of bmx games and uh
ssx obviously
super cool uh back in the day
pro skater so nice yeah oh man i love
this ssx
ssx tricky yep yeah for the original
xbox so good so decorated as a game both
of those and like wasn't there like a
1080 snowboarding something with 1080.
what's also what's the one that's like
dark something where you you're going
downhill it's kind of like got a dark
summit that game is oh i don't think
i've played that
game that's like
ps2 maybe
yeah it's like an rpg game it was in the
ps2 original xbox uh
generation but it's it's like it's like
rpg elements and story but you're racing
downhill through all these different
levels trying to complete objectives
it's pretty cool
um and then somebody in somebody's chat
said excite mike are you that old oh
salute yeah that's right
scotty b that's og yeah yeah i i that
was on i think i played that game on the
the game boy the old brick the original
bro that's where i played that one wow i
played like some escape from camp
simpson's game on i mean i played other
things on gameboy but that's one of
those random ones i played and i still
remember that game was an absolute pain
in the butt to beat too but yeah game
boy in the break
these games are hardcore there's a star
wars game where you you have to play as
like an ewok and you kill emperor
palpatine which was canon by the way
that was one of the seven times emperor
palpatine died according to his old
wikipedia page
um
he's only died
this day this day that we don't pick one
yeah yeah literally the the entry said
these years to these years then these
years are the easiest than these years
of these years now it only says it twice
okay so disney's really rained it in all
of the oh techmobile oh yeah scotty said
tecmo
and tecmo super bowl those were like old
school football games and you get bo
jackson just like run by everybody i
think that's who that was you could play
with
yeah i forgot of course how could how
would you forget um
uh
uh the the the football game where like
you're like punching people in the face
what's that one called blitz was a blast
okay so here's one i gotta see if you
guys if anybody ever played this base
wars
hmm
tell me about esports uh basically it's
robots playing
baseball
go look it up it's on like nes yeah it's
idiots it came out in 1991
i never tend to find people who have
ever played bass wars oh yeah i'm seeing
it right now you had robots playing
baseball you could get like different
upgrades and like yeah
they had like horsepower there was like
it was an oddly deep game like yeah look
it up ultra games is a publisher wow
i played that i never hear anybody talk
about on the snes was combat basketball
it was like a sci-fi sci-fi basketball
game where like your characters had like
jet boots and you'd like fly in the air
and it was pretty cool like multiplayer
game but yeah and then if you get into
like racing games which sometimes sports
and racing games are combined because i
feel like yeah they just made a they
made a genre for games nobody likes and
just disrespected each other in the
corner yeah uh but yeah the like if you
get into car games like my history with
like which one is let's go along gran
turismo
on the ps1 days nice
licenses
huge forts of fame oh dude that's how i
learned to drive no joke i was a poor
kid literally i took those license
classes like in gran turismo that's how
i that's how i learned to drive straight
up like crazy
wow
yeah i'm very excited for four to five
by the way like that's gonna be one of
my uh big huge
huge huge but i will also say like for
me i also died a little bit inside this
week
because of a very specific destiny
reasons yes for non-destiny reasons a
very specific delay
has me just like
yeah so elden ring which was gonna come
out like was it january 30th like three
weeks from horizon horizon and like
which queen they were going to be four
days apart that was already like i can
try we'll see who knows
now which i'm sure everybody's heard
about if you follow gaming websites i
just haven't you know talked about it
too much on my stuff
horizon zero dawn is on february 18th
witch queen sabathune are on february
22nd eldon ring saints row and there's i
think one other one in there as well
which i'm probably forgetting are on the
25th
that was on the 18th no no that was 18th
so you've got seven days and you've got
five games three of which you take
horizon eldon and destiny large open
worlds like 50 hours 50 hours that's
what it is
ragnarok that's the other that's
[Laughter]
that's all
yeah but no it's like so i was gonna
have like three solid weeks to just be
me and eldon ring and however long it
took me for for me to get through it
probably the quiet time after any
festivals maybe salsa stuff which
shouldn't take too long
and then now it's a week of hell and for
me actually because i like i don't want
to do what travis just described like 50
hours in a short amount of time to try
and like play horizon because i want to
enjoy it because then you know which
queen is going to suck up we like every
waking minute that you've got but then
three days later eldon ring comes out so
even if i start horizon eldon ring is
gonna be tugging at me to check it out
so it's like i don't even know when i'm
gonna start either and i still don't
know which one i'm gonna start first but
i'm just like well you know damn well
you're playing we're going to stop it
seafood
is on the 22nd that's what i'm playing
which one which one do you say saints
row saints rose on the table i'll play
for when i'm waiting when i'm waiting in
the queue because i can't get in the
server i mean that's fair
you know day one we not you know you're
not getting in that server day one
yeah i'm not a while it's in the queue
if i'll switch inputs or on it on the
oled and go right over the seafood
wait you know what's going on
i used to take the day of release off
and then i started to learn over
multiple destiny releases to take the
day after release
he knows what really goes on with these
launches you have never taken i've made
that mistake so many times and you
sitting there
me too i would have to take two days off
because of like one would just be a
wasted day and then the other one i
would actually get to play absolutely
now i don't have to take any days off
because my job is to review destiny when
it comes out hey there you go
that's the good stuff that's right baby
that's right that's right yeah i was
like that was that was just like for me
i was like it was looking so like
horizon was still gonna get neglected
just as it did last time because of
zelda but
eldon ring was at least gonna get like
some dedicated time and now
i think cause it's gonna be friday and
depending on where the raid falls if you
want to be in that thing even for you
know even a halfway attempt of like day
one which i'm sure teddy will have at
day one which is fine but even if i just
want to be in a group to see it blind
it's still
there's a fair amount of dedication up
until that thing kicks off and which
like eldering is just like kind of
distracting from it so
yeah i was not thrilled it's gonna be
rough but february will be a bit spicy
and now january doesn't have a whole lot
i'm looking forward to like january no
yeah it's fine dude you're gonna be
playing halo you're gonna be like
the december releases are pretty
ridiculous so i think you'll be fine in
january you're gonna have so much to
catch up on my backlog is forever so
that's true backlog's crazy yeah i've
been doing my backlog too
february 22nd is a tuesday right yes
they always do tuesday i'm sure
they wouldn't do it otherwise
it's gonna be crazy crazy but yeah you
may as well not try and log into like
movie industry you're still afraid of
the movie industry well i mean but then
elden rings a friday he got what is it
saints rosa friday and then horizons of
friday before that
so that's all weekend based so yeah
games industry been adapting with the
with the release dates and apparently
february is now out of the way
yes they did
and that's kind of led the way i'm sorry
teddy
skyrim skyrim and nintendo were the
first oh that's right yeah took to
release the game on a friday um granted
skyrim was doing like the date because
it was the one one one
you know yeah
2011 thing but yeah uh nintendo was the
first one really to be like screw
tuesday we're doing friday and then
everyone kind of was like oh movies
don't matter for video games like
yeah yeah yeah i also give them credit
for um i think nintendo kind of like
pioneered that march
kind of springy like i remember the
switch was a big deal like people like
it's coming out in march and it's like
constantly killed and like breath of the
wild killed and it was just like well i
mean you literally
you did a brand new zelda banger with
lunch like yeah i mean that's one of the
best games that they're gonna have on
the console for
it is still one of them yeah and it was
the first game that came out yeah until
the sequel comes out with the next
switch or whatever switch to is or
something who knows but they're the only
company that can release a
major product like a console in march
and get away with it if microsoft or
sony did that it would they would not it
wouldn't work until the holidays i agree
i completely agree they changed the game
with that i i remembered i was like wow
the one i remember is uh
dying light do you guys remember that
that was like a junior relationship
it came out in like january or february
and i remember games were not coming out
at that time and people kept referring
to it as like a sleeper hit or because
like it came out of time nobody was
expecting and it was like a really
popular game and then after that i
remember being like oh yeah people are
going to start releasing in that window
and now it's like
now i feel like there are more games
coming out in the spring than in
than in the fall
at least this year because there's so
many damn delays i agree like i agree
yeah it's kind of crazy crazy because i
i honestly would get resentful
especially if you like xbox like
a lot of stuff always was just
jam-packed it was always november i'm
like oh my god like it was it was just
crazy so i like these spread out
cadences i like these spread out
releases and it's just what it is what
we realize is just so many damn games
every month for the most part or every
other month is something substantial you
know that is you know usually moves the
needle in some way so gaming has changed
man all those like norms and tropes
really thrown out the window you can
kind of release when you want if the
game's big enough and you got the space
yeah i think nintendo really nailed it
with the
when the switch came out they
essentially have been using this the
same model for the last five years which
is you have like your quarterly big
zelda mario pokemon animal crossing and
then every single month of the year
there's a there's a minor um
game like a mario party or or uh you
know it's still like a first party game
but sort of like a spin-off usually and
they've been doing that basically since
launch um yeah yeah warriors and like
that and it's uh it's totally working
for them because they're constantly in
the conversation
it's usually the number one selling
console and
it works
seven-year-old hardware
i bought that oled just for the ethernet
port teddy
fun fact uh because of the usbc port as
well as nintendo's bad servers yeah
actually cap side at about 100 megabits
per second
wow
[Music]
that's still got even faster than their
actual wireless though oh i'm sure i
mean it is but yeah but it's it's
abysmal like i just i'm doing the
transfer right now and i'm 100 megabits
is abysmal and people in like rural
texas are like i will happily take that
all right
well it's a make a bit yeah
why you have to completely put him in
that category like like he is that guy
you're hilarious he's jealous
have you not forgotten my my debut on
the show oh yeah dallas yeah could not
forget he's just
i was like do you know where i was born
not in texas
where were you born
i doubt you'd even guess
because i don't resemble it anyway nope
i went to school there but no
chico state you're born on the college
campus
arizona state university
i was born in connecticut if that tells
you anything connecticut wow and i lived
in both sacramento and rancho palos
verdes but i was too young to remember
that one so i feel like you were born in
a fraternity house you look like you
were i'll just say that
i don't even know how to take that but
i'm pretty
you're a bit of a jerk for saying it
whatever is going on in there i don't
think i came off well that's all i got
to say
savage
oh my god i'm done i'm done so what's
going on with this game
there's this bungie thing
i love you i guess the question is where
to we got to begin with what happened
earlier in the week right we got to be
begin with the news that happened from a
reddit post with a bit of clarification
uh sorry dmg for the quotes there um
but basically with what was going on
with the dungeons
and the witch queen deluxe edition
season passes and how everything's being
given to you next year
so bring some you guys up to speed in
case you haven't either seen my video
that i already did which some of you
have
or if you just you know enjoy this show
and find it somewhere else
basically what was going on is you've
got the standard edition of witch queen
which is literally your campaign the
raid the new glade the weapon crafting
you're going to avoid 3.0 free updates
and stuff like that that's your standard
it's 40 bucks
and this is u.s prices in case you're
everywhere else i know dakota's probably
going to be playing 50 more
then you've got the deluxe edition of
which queen
you've got everything i just said with
the normal then you've got the four
seasons
16 17 18 19. you've got two dungeons and
you've got uh smg ornament and catalyst
and then you've got like a cosmetic
sparrow or something
now one distinction already there that
some people may not have been aware of
or may not have realized even though i
honestly forgot beyond light work this
way but some didn't used to season 16
that runs concurrently with witch queen
is not included with witch queen
now beyond light worked the same way
because you can actually see beyond
light beyond light plus one season or
beyond light deluxe for the whole year
i've always bought the deluxe i haven't
really paid attention to that but if you
go back to say shadow keep
um i cannot remember the name of the
season with all the vex invasion on the
moon off the top of my head
oh yeah unknown season
that came with shadow keep so if you
bought shadow keep you got the season of
undying but you know say like season
worthy and season of dawn those were
separate afterwards
um so this time season 16 17 18 19
and the two dungeons that stuff that's
part of the deluxe package then you have
the 30th anniversary that's just an
add-on from there but you have 80 bucks
or 40 bucks the big distinction
came to light basically when it was
clarified by cosmo
to say
if you buy the standard
you can upgrade to the deluxe later get
the whole package of the seasons and the
dungeons if you buy the standard
and then of course if you buy the deluxe
you got it all so that's covering
everything but if you buy the standard
and then say you buy like
season 17
which most people would assume where one
of the dungeons is gonna fall because
they're likely gonna go raid dungeon
raid dungeon say you buy season 17 the
dungeon that will launch during that
season is not included in that season
same thing with which one ever the other
one is
so now
a lot of things seem separated
so one of the comments was like thank
you for the information but i know
you're about to get eviscerated for this
like
i mean the community managers have a
tough job even today like my tweet that
blew up which we'll get to here in a
little while um even if it was a bug
which they're working on at the moment
community managers shout out to cosmo
dmg nicole who doesn't do as much of the
forward-facing stuff she's more
marketing and figured out
those guys never have any easy job
anybody handling that so just hats off
to those guys for having an ultra thick
skin because it's not their choice to
code anything or choose pricing they are
like the delivers of all the messages so
i wanted to shout out a shout out
both of those um gentlemen for all of
the crap that they tend to take
that being said
we are at a point where we discussed
this literally last week pricing's
getting a little questionable and now
we're literally dividing and portioning
up it even more depending on when you
come to this and they're in a sense
pushing you in a certain direction which
is obviously the deluxe but if somebody
does end up
at a point where they all cart some of
this stuff they really are going to be
in a weird spot come middle of season 18
and be like all right what do i have to
buy to play the stuff that i want to
and it's almost going to be a hard
explanation and i know what it is right
now but later on i'm not going to be
able to tell you so that's the general
idea uh i wanted to get you guys takes
on this one teddy as we brought you in
as a guest because i know you got some
very smooth talking but nice hot takes
coming in uh you get to go first because
yeah i'm just kind of curious who takes
on this one actually i haven't heard
yours on this yet
yeah that's true so
[Music]
we kind of talked about this last time i
was on the show but
the pricing structure is like all was
already kind of ridiculous like travis i
think really nailed this
and now they're just adding like another
layer to this
mess
um like we're we're in the thick of it
so we understand
i'm not saying we accept it but we
understand
what's like
kind of interesting was it it felt like
dr strange we in the end game now
the way you said it was
now i gotta get a wizard for halloween i
beat it
oh i already know my costume for
halloween
[Laughter]
i hope you're not wearing that scarf and
that heat oh that would be hilarious
yeah i just want the cinnamon somebody
wore a giant cinnamon toast crunch
costume to i think it was a mets game
go look it up there's a cinnamon toast
crunch costume and somebody's in and
it's like behind the um behind the
umpire and he's like ball and the
cinnamon toast crunch guy's like colin
call it anyway sorry back to where you
are okay so
like we
we understand the pricing structure i'm
not saying like we're okay with it but
we have a general like a good
understanding of how it works but like
just talk to any of your casual destiny
friends and without explaining any of it
none of the controversy none of the
the hoopla just be like
read this does this make sense to you
and i guarantee you they're gonna have
questions
uh
it
i think i think they
someone in a board meeting in a in the
business minds
were like how do we get more money
and
on paper it makes sense and that's their
job is to get more money
but then we get to get the consumer part
of it and we're like
no this just doesn't work
um
i think it's really telling in hindsight
now that they release prophecy for free
because i think that was an experiment
i think that was
can we release this for free and what's
the
feedback slash monetization we get off
this
okay now we're we're advertising that a
whole year's worth of seasonal content
is one rare two raids two dungeons now
we gotta charge for this because this is
the aspirational endgame
content and so that's i'm assuming
that's their justification for how
they're uh going to charge for it um
i think there's a way better way to
price this i don't know what that
solution is i'm not gonna pretend like i
know the the metrics behind it but
there's got to be a better way than like
okay you can buy the 60 version of the
game and then there's a 80 version of
the game and there's also the dungeons
separately and then there's this other
stuff and like there's there has to be a
better way to do this like this this
just doesn't work uh in in my mind but
maybe there are enough gullible people
that are
do that are buying it that i guess
they're making enough money um
the other thing too that i think is is
tangibly related is
they announce forsaken is gonna get
sunset
and then you can still buy forsaken
right now like you can spend money on it
uh that's that's
that i will say is like the one part in
my video that i said is like you have
some of this you have some of the
nerfs
you're good um with regards to festival
which we'll kind of talk about a little
later too but a couple things recently
have been doing that and then for me the
one that is and i said this previously
is the fact that you can go to
steam right now and i've seen it's
discounted on like playstation or xbox
it might be a little bit cheaper but if
i go to steam right now forsaken is
24.99
there is no re the only people that
that's going to get are the uninformed
and that is like the worst person you
want to take advantage of to then
basically burn because
anybody who's like hey ibanta should i
go play destiny i'm like well
if you wait six weeks this will be free
you can experience this
you might be able to look for sales for
some of these other things but it's like
somebody was just like hey i picked up
destiny for free what's the oldest
campaign okay forsaken i think that was
the one that came up first let me start
there to get the story going and see
what's up
that's the only person that's gonna get
probably pay the 24.99 is the uninformed
and that doesn't feel good to me and
that was i wanted to like pull that out
again because i think honestly as soon
as they made that announcement that
should have been free because it's a
limited time that it's only going to be
costing you money anyway so it's like it
may as well be it's like hey by the way
forsaken's free for the next
four months instead of two you got
somebody who wants to play it it's
totally free have your friends go check
out what happens in that campaign see if
they want to join and get ready that's a
good pr move and again hogue said the
same thing he's like talking about
messaging and pr and everything else is
like that's the good way to do it as
opposed to right now is like trying to
catch the unsuspected for money and i'm
like that feels
scummy and as you said for like the
board to make a
money decision it's like
money versus like public image at some
point you can only like pull so many
times at that before it does burn you so
i won't i'm sorry to interrupt but that
did want to say that that was good this
is the last thing i'm gonna do this is
my controversial take that i
generally don't say this publicly
i like teddy intuition takes gang i
bungie has conditioned their fan base
in such a way because they were one of
the first if not the first to do what
they're doing
that their fan base
as much as they complain
will always be okay with this this kind
of stuff in the long run and because
they
so intuitively understand the marketing
push
in in a month and a half when they
release something oh
they absolutely announce the forsaken
information and the dungeon information
right now when they know the player base
is probably low and people aren't paying
as much attention because other stuff is
going on they're correct they're not
stupid no one at bungie's stupid like
they they know what's going on so they i
i believe that they have conditioned
their player base in such a way that
uh
people people will always be okay with
this um maybe not me personally or maybe
not you guys but um it's just it's just
the way this game works like no other
game gets away with any of the stuff
they're doing it's almost like nintendo
nintendo also has really scummy powers
sometimes too man world of warcraft too
but we didn't have expansion pass online
right but we know it's a nintendo right
so we're like bluetooth nintendo yeah
it was there the whole time it was
that i think that burned me harder than
anything else recently when i figured
out that that was a software update
for my four-year-old og switch that's
sitting over here that now can pair with
i was like are you i
um i was so bad at that
yeah so
like i i just think they're they're one
of those companies that they have
they've built up so much grace over the
years with people or goodwill with
players that they can reasonably get
away with with a lot of stuff uh that
and their their messaging is it's very
usually careful how they how they if you
look at the wording like think about the
destiny content involved for example i
was actually thinking about this a few
weeks ago
uh it came it popped in my head that
it's just like the disney vault the
disney did the exact same thing it was
like we're gonna vault this thing and
make it seem like we're not taking it
away from you and then sell it to you
later which is like
hogue
that's crazy to me
who can get away with that no one can
get away with that there's very few
companies that can get away with that
disney so sorry bunji i love you guys
but like
come on this is a little ridiculous
yeah yeah
travis where are you at travis
uh
uh i have uh i have i've been talking
about this for so many years i talked
about it on fire team chat when this was
like a very early concern basically when
like microtransactions rolled out like
at the beginning of destiny 2 and as
they progressively got worse
and uh
i still think that bungie is so so
behind the curve on it and i don't know
that it's malicious i think it's just
the fact that they don't know what their
business model is and they're trying
everything right like they've got the
the micro transactions of a free-to-play
game they've got the season pass model
of a games as a service game they've got
uh the expansions of a aaa game and now
they've got piecemail add-ons of like a
game that has like dlc right um and they
they just haven't they haven't gotten
rid of any of their legacy ones
and
obviously something needs to change i
don't think this solution as a lot of
people in the community are suggesting
is to go to a subscription model for a
few reasons one i think the subscription
model is super outdated i don't think it
has a place in the current ecosystem of
video games really anywhere there's some
games that could get away with it like
wow but i just don't think that
when you have games like apex that are
free you can just log on and play them
for free the entire time games that have
its own subscription are like dinosaurs
to me like i i can't even wrap my head
around that and the fact that you're
going to then put a subscription model
and lock stuff behind it like
microtransactions which let's be honest
those are never going away right but
like that that season
the vault she ain't getting announced to
get into the content yet and and the
thing that i think really really scares
me
is that when players destiny players are
saying they need to move to subscription
model what they are not thinking about
is the distinct possibility that bungie
listens to them and doesn't change
anything about their model
when they're already charging you they
just add a subscription because if you
think that that's an impossibility think
about what's happened the entire time
destiny 2 has been a game they've been
adding models and not removing old ones
so if you think that it's impossible
that they could then go subscription and
then keep all the other ways they're
charging you you're out of your mind in
my opinion right so like it it scares me
that people are like giving them more
reasons or more ways that they could
potentially charge us and thinking like
oh yeah if they add this way obviously
the old ways of doing it will go away i
just don't really buy that i think i
think bungie must be making enough money
with season passes or they could charge
more for season passes with seasonal
content with micro transactions to do
away entirely with charging us for the
major expansions or like the major
content and i i really do not believe
anybody who says that like oh they need
the money for major expansions or that
they need to charge us for dungeons
separately i just don't believe that i
i see them building new campuses and
hiring hundreds of employees and all the
stuff and all my friends who play
destiny spend like 60 dollars every time
there's an event they buy all these not
to call you out dj oros but you you just
your whole
and i'm like this guy is just that's
dj's that's my guy he's not the only guy
everybody
lots of people they spend money on this
stuff
and i just i just don't i just don't
believe that they that they need the old
way of doing it i think that they're
afraid of doing it or that they just
haven't put a lot of thought into it
because they're so focused on just
creating content and growing the
business which i totally get but they've
created a bit of a monster when it comes
to this and it's not friendly to their
players and it's also
i think more importantly super hard to
navigate like you guys are saying if you
don't buy the deluxe edition you're in
for it dude like you have the fact that
they don't know that if you buy forsaken
you can't play it in a couple months and
now they're gonna sell you an individual
dungeon that will someday be content
vaulted you have to assume right so
you're paying like 10 bucks for this one
specific thing that's gonna go away
eventually and i i think that that does
not fit the
the model of putting things in a vault
and taking it out and having that
ability describing all of the content on
your game as part of a live service that
could go away at any time does not match
with the model of selling people
expansions selling people piecemeal
dungeons none of that makes sense they
just need to get rid of that and come up
with a new model i mean it would be
man it's like it would be the bungee
number just to make it seven dollars and
77 cents a month
yeah savage no but okay so
no it was like that's just entertainment
but i was like so okay so what is
the solution to this though because you
take something like witch queen which in
theory is which queen in the full year
of content for it's 6.67 cents a month
if you break it out that's what it costs
so
in turn is it upfront or monthly
if that covers everything that you're
going to do for the year do you care
which way it gets you
i say neither i say both of those models
are bad i i think charging for
expansions does not fit a live service
game and charging subscriptions is an
outdated way of doing it they've got
micro transactions in the game they have
season passes they have a seasonal model
their entire game is built around a
games as a service model like fortnite
or apex and they are the only ones who
think that they should be charging for
expansions or considering subscription
or any stuff like that i don't think
they need either i really don't
which cream draws people to your game
and then incentivizing them with
microtransactions and selling them
season passes
is how you make your money
i think charging for the expansions is
fine if
nothing gets vaulted and the reason i
say that is
a mutual friend of ours recently asked
me how i feel about the vaulting of
forsaken and the i've said this on the
show as well before
i can right now
go buy a used copy of halo 3 or halo
reach or halo 4 for
a few dollars at most
put it into my xbox 360 and that game
for the most part with few balancing
because there were a couple patches for
each game will play exactly the way it
played when it released with all the
content and any post content that came
out
you can't have a game
like destiny and remove an entire chunk
of the story that was already confusing
to begin with for the average person
and then be like oh yeah you can start
here now at this point and forget about
all that other stuff that happened but
if you were there you were there and
that's kind of cool but it just doesn't
it doesn't because now every time i
spend money it's like well
this only exists for three years
and i get the like hours argument like
yeah 40 40 80 a year for
in an insane amount of hours is fine
whatever but
i maybe in 10 years i want to go back
and i want to play forsaken
and i can't do that
uh i can't play the original that's a
joke that's a live service game you also
can't you can't go and watch a fortnight
event that already happened like there's
just that's that's the live service
model so my point in all of this is if
expansions are going to get vaulted you
can't sell expansions you can't sell
people content that you're going to take
away that's my philosophy on that and
the reason i think the subscription
model is bad is because the barrier of
entry is too high and games these days
are going the opposite direction
lowering barriers and making people play
allowing people to play at least a less
premium experience unless they pay so
the only solution is
expand what is in season passes and just
sell season passes and then you can sell
microtransactions on top of that
cosmetics all the eververse stuff keep
doing that but make make a season pass
twenty five dollars a season so you okay
that was about that i was gonna say
what's your price
make it more expensive put the raid
behind it put the end game content
behind it but then leave the campaign
and most of the stuff as like a free to
play model that anybody can access
without even buying anything that that's
what everyone else does it's like
why aren't they doing that that's the
free to play that's the uh games as a
service model
so and and yeah you're right
teddy i think the reason is because
money and because destiny is probably
more expensive to make than a lot of
other games as a service games but i
don't think that that is the player's
problem and i also don't think that the
player should be expected to pay for
stuff that's gonna be vaulted or
have to deal with a subscription just to
get in your game because that's insane
like that model was just so old to me i
just yeah i i agree with most of what
you're saying but before we hang out
enough cogs he hasn't a chance to get
his grievances out would you be okay if
when they announced an expansion and it
comes out if they slapped a date on
there and said this gets vaulted in uh
2025. let's see they basically already
do that
but
they tell you and they tell you hey once
the season's over you're not going to be
able to fight uh kyle or anything like
that like that's sort of already
well this year they changed it so that
every season because it's actually
active now before but previous years
wasn't like that that's what yeah they
you know they at least listen to us a
little bit but but i mean like now when
the witch queen comes out we know all
the stuff's gonna be vaulted so we
essentially had a date when we got it
right like
yeah i mean that's basically
at least it's not three months we are up
to a year at this point for the seasonal
stuff but yes the seasonal
live service stuff is you're talking
about does have an end date it's more on
the expansion the campaigns and stuff
like that i think he's asking if which
queen comes out and says hey this will
be vaulted in 2025 which at this point
there's three years left in the
franchise you can assume everything has
an end date
they're not selling me the witch queen
and the model i'm proposing they're
selling me the season right and so i i'm
saying make the witch queen free and
make the campaign free but then put the
end game the premium stuff that's what
the most hardcore players are going to
play put that behind the season pass
explain what's in the season pass and
then and then tell me what i'm getting
but like it's very everyone understands
what they're getting when they pay for
season pass they're paying for
experience in a window where they can
earn content and they can access premium
features and that sort of stuff people
don't really even understand what
they're getting anymore when they buy an
expansion and when you're selling a
subscription you definitely don't know
what you're getting because you're the
basic
subscription is you have access to
whatever's in the game right now and
some of that can go away and there's a
barrier of entry and it it would kill
their player base i mean talk about uh
accessibility i mean a subscription is
the opposite of
accessibility so i i just think that
that can't be the solution here cog
where are you at
yeah um a lot to digest lots of digest
um
i think trav nailed it way back
you know when we were talking about
the separation right and we were talking
about the separation from activision and
we were talking about
you know how they're going to operate
going forward as this indie studio right
we knew tess was the
you know
the thing in the room that elephant in
the room you know it's not gonna go away
we all know that right i think when
things got murky for me was the
combination of the introduction of the
vault
right
and then um
once i'm gonna be honest to me this is
what i kind of changed on them
was at eat me you had this conversation
when
what you call transmog was introduced
and we saw
such a negative reaction we all felt
that as far as the implementation of it
the way it was handled was probably the
worst
transmog implementation compared to
other games that have it either for free
or more customization and more more
features
and what's up smitty smith salute bro
thank you thank you last words the best
word
but you know at the end of the day it's
like
and the the key thing to me e was
i mean everyone was unified this was not
a goal bungie this was not a goal right
and the key thing for me
was the lack
of mention
of any true change to that system
and it was kind of like we're not going
to talk about this this time
we're going to move on
right the best we got was a little
synthetic thread in a center strand
maybe slight reduction but as far as
people were like yo this doesn't even
need to be here fam like while we
monetizing it to this level like what's
going on here and when i knew that
didn't go away
and my home i told you i said you i
don't think i think they're gonna eat
the bullet on this one oh yeah i mean
that's a decision that they
if you've seen transmog in enough of
their games you know what it
theoretically can work as
and then when we had the discussion that
nearly broke travis we were talking
about five different currencies and he
nearly fell out of the screen like
yeah like that's one of those points
where
you're like how convoluted time gated
there's no way they don't know it takes
you 180 whatever hours like there
somebody does the math they know that
stuff in advance
we know bungie's not dumb nobody exactly
ever said they're not stupid they're
actually very intelligent data driven
like there are people doing things
typically for a reason which is why some
of these questions always do tend to
come up as to what is the proper model i
mean i looked up final fantasy 14 it's
one of the rare pieces where a
subscription model does actually work
now granted the big factor there is
content doesn't get vaulted you can go
back and play what is it realm reborn
which is when it it did die and then get
rebooted hence the name actually works
pretty well it's also an mmo not a live
service game like this it's sort of
that's and that's the piece of where you
have like
a different style of game you know you
have content that doesn't go away the
subscription model and i think that's
kind of
i i don't want to take i'm going to put
a pin in this so cog you can finish but
i have something i'll say when i come
back yeah no
yeah it's just it's just the thing for
me is you know i'm always gonna be
listen i'm always pro deaf that that
i've always said that like i've always
i know how hard it is that these guys
are working i'm never going to
disrespect content at all you got to do
but i'm with teddy
on the fact that to me since the
separation there has been a clear
distinction as far as the boardroom and
corporate money makers having the
ultimate say on how things are going to
proceed moving forward and i think now
we are seeing the results of it just
like travis is saying this is the only
game that is allowed to have like six
monetization models
and none
none
none get vaulted
the older models
still exist right that's the problem and
and
again to what teddy is saying
the the thing that is most frustrating
is i love this game
i want people to play this game they
come to me and they say cog what do i do
where do i start should i get this
should i get forsaken
what about the season past how do you
get that exotic how come i don't have
that how do you get with the hoard where
did you get that from it it's it's this
because again
all these models
all this convolution and then you jump
in you don't know where to start and
then you're talking about now vaulting
campaign
so you can't even get an idea on what to
start and where's the the narrative
going right so
and i got to give hog his props like
it's not our problem
no that's not our problem bunch i'm
sorry like that is not our problem that
you don't have it straightened out and
i'm not trying to be disrespectful but i
want people to play this game that we
all love i every month it's like i gotta
go research okay so this is going okay
this is here all right all right you
know what start there right and then to
your point e which is super egregious
let's just call it out
you can't have forsaken still up in
there
yeah sure bro that's a that's a horrible
look that's a hard that is deception
you know that's going away there's not
even a disclaimer expires on december
20. that's a bad look you can't do that
to people to spend 25 bucks on something
that's literally
mostly gone yeah dreaming city's still
there and they're gonna be the four
second pack but in theory most of what
you buy is gone in
what four months yeah and my last point
i give it to you for the record again
this is not going out at the community
managers this is not going out to the
creators the developers who are this is
the business people the money making
people who are literally perm and now
it's getting to the point e where it's
like
well who was really holding who back
with activision and like it's get people
are coming to me like oh yeah like
there's the question maybe this was
y'all all along
i mean there's literally
you should have seen the comments in my
video you know a controversial video is
always entertaining when you check the
number of comments
versus the number of views like compared
to one of my other videos was like hey
here's the guide and some people are
like hey thanks this helped me out so
and so it's like those are going to be
sometimes but then
the ratio of comments to the views on
that video i was like oh man it got just
absolutely lit up so
yeah it's like it's we are in a point to
where
new red chevy no game will kill destiny
but destiny
i was like it is i mean you guys have
all said it it's like
they they haven't settled on something
there's too many different activities
going on if you think about a
subscription which would
smooth things out and this is kind of
what i was trying to get back to is
with everything they've done recently if
they and some of these like you've got
the vaulting where things don't go
you've got dungeons that are separate
you've got the occasional nerfs that
happen in live service like holiday
events and you've got certain things
that happen have had to have happened to
enough people and now the fact that red
war doesn't exist forsaken's not gonna
exist
and like
like a subscription model is well i was
just gonna say like a subscription model
is a terrifying word for them to say i'm
sure it's something they don't want to
say because as travis said it's very
outdated makes people think of wow and
god why what the hell would i ever way
back
it's an old thing and final fantasy 14
is a rare bird right now because it's
like it's doing something very special
but again it's also has a whole lot of
work and you know they've managed to
support and grow it not like chop and
limit and stuff like that we've got but
i know they've always been afraid of
saying anything like that to really
because there was somebody in the
comments either when i was live on
twitch or
one of the videos they're like if it's
ever a live subscription i'm out it's
just like that fast as a reaction and
that's what some people and it's like so
they don't want to do that are you
trying to get your friends into this
game cog was just talking about getting
his friends in if you tell them oh yeah
hop back in you just got to sign up for
your subscription that's like a hard no
oh yeah oh yeah that's like no i'm not
going to sign up for a subscription even
elder scrolls online super successful i
was thinking about describe that as an
mmo they have a subscription but you
don't have to pay for it right free to
play and then they they gate the
subscription and gives you a bunch of
stuff so a lot of people are subscribers
but you don't need it you know what i
mean i just think that's what is the
i'll give it right back to you because i
know you're flowing the last one i'm
going to say is where it really bothered
me this week
is um
you're flowing you're moving baby you're
moving out
what really bothered me this week is
that i always have a problem
when there's precedent set
and then you renege on that
and what i mean is with the dungeons
you know
we've always had
the dungeon and the raid comes part of
said expansion or said you know season
and to say
yo
you're not getting this
unless you get the super deluxe with
extra sauce and
like hundred dollar you know what i'm
saying you gotta get the full combo meal
you're not going all a cart yeah like
bro i can't get the chicken nuggets
separate like why i gotta like you
really forcing me to do all this like
come on like it it's a bad look because
the if you look at the the witch queen
winners was like a hundred something
right the one the the deluxe is eighty
and then the thirtieth is a hundred
the thirtieth is there one more like we
never did this before
like why are we doing this new thing
then you already got the heat from
removing
it's like each month is a new
evil monetization edition
it's like awesome it also just makes it
so confusing like what do you what is
the season pass include now like is it
literally just the uh xp bar
are you getting the activity as well
like the fact that they're selling the
dungeon separately just adds another
layer of confusion that's why i think
they just need to simplify it keep
eververse and expand what the season
pass includes right because then it
makes sense then it's like okay well
obviously witch queen doesn't come with
the with the other dungeons or the other
raid because those happen in different
seasons so you're buying the witch queen
season and then you can buy the next
season if you want that dungeon but the
the fact that they're not doing that
that they're just like seasons one
season pass is one thing
microtransactions are another thing
expansions are one thing and then
there's also these activities oh and if
you want to transmog also a separate
thing that you pay for that's just too
confusing
and then people are like why don't they
add a subscription or like are you
kidding me you're like giving them more
ideas do you think they're gonna take
away some of the ones they've already
done they're not that's the only one
like that's the only way they ever could
is you would have to like you would
really have to consolidate everything to
ever consider a subscription but as you
said right now that would be a big
overhaul with so many different pieces
they have they'd be like all right
starting in 2020 the only time they
could ever do that is like
destiny
whatever is after the light dark saga if
like we are going to a different model
you know it's all whatever you want to
do like that would be the time when
they've got a new engine and this comes
back to even today's
issue which we'll talk about is what we
joke about every so often
is if you can't support the game that
you built in the first place with the
engine that it's currently on
that leads to issues of what are the
next three years gonna be like
and that makes you wonder it's like how
long can you limp this engine to and
this is where again where if bungie's
ever listened to this it's like we love
you but you're gonna hate me right now
yeah you're gonna lift up you're gonna
limp an old engine for three more years
to pay for two other games that they're
working on the studio employees which
again
please pay your employees take care of
them i hear bungie has some of the best
working conditions benefits straight up
like it has got to be one of the best
places to work as a developer from what
i hear
ups and downs but i was like
they are like if you get a job there you
are probably very happy to work there
but again you turn around and say you're
like okay so i've got
this old thing that we're trying to limp
along that you want us to talk about
and
you know discuss and play and make
content on and all this other thing but
it's like then we have something where
we put out a hot fix and then you break
something else
and it's like we joked about the
spaghetti code and it's like you know
that's not a great term to use but at
this point you are at a you are looking
at an occasional house of cards where
it's like you're gonna make one of those
little towers fall if you sneeze on it
wrong because it is in a fragile state
and we have to look three years out in
this same thing to try and get as long
as we can out of this
when finally it's like okay this thing
is finally done
we have to retire this engine and stuff
we finally put spent the last three
years to built a next-gen version of it
which is fine
but it's like what do you look at until
then it's like
you can't keep what's in forsaken
okay then when does the shadow keep go
next well do you get rid of shadow keep
because that's the moon you took the
time to revamp the moon and put it into
your game with like new lighting and
revamp stuff like that do you take that
away we do keep the dreaming city but
then forsaken's gone and then you're
playing this like tetris little like cup
game where you're trying to find the
thing that's going to be moved around
and actually see what actually makes it
go ahead
real quick i'll give it right back no
you're good you're so right think about
this in turn forget about us right as a
player
think about you're the dev like hulk
said
you make content for a season right
and then your hard work
you everything that you invested from a
development that's why you're now thrown
away shattered realm is my best example
this season right now the amount of work
put into the shattered realm this season
as much of an amazing piece of content
that is is gone when witch queen comes
out and that hurts also probably hurts
even as much whoever made that because
people are gonna be like oh i'm coming
into witch queen this is gonna be a lot
of fun the devs like well i made this
really cool metroidvania in here even on
a resume that can be like i hope you can
see this youtube video of my resume
because you can't go look at it in game
right now it's like as you said that's
gotta hurt for bungie it's like it is a
great place to work but yeah the limited
nature of some of the content is that's
gotta be rough on them too
they're not throwing it away okay
they're putting it in the vault they
will sell it to you again in 10
version years going to be quantity hd
quad hd now or qhd
it'll be a vr version of the game yeah
they're going to take it out of the
vault you just wait
i actually don't have a problem with the
like the getting rid of it part because
like that's just part of the industry
now with live service games i think you
make content knowing like okay this is a
special experience that they get to see
yeah but it's different from like that's
different from like a fortnight concert
versus
shatter drone like that is not even
remotely the same and the amount of
effort it takes to make yeah like that's
not these are some illustrious sky boxes
correct but there's lots of other games
that are like that uh but not to the
level monster hunter warframe uh i mean
i could go on and on there's this is
free like monster hunter sea of thieves
sea of thieves
would you would you compare like
a leviathan says
i don't feel it's on the same scale as
destiny i feel destiny's the level of
complexity with just encounters
and sky boxes and gun play is superior
to anything out of those other games
those games are just about game
compatibility i'm talking about the
concept like
warframe concepts
i just think like
this is
for whatever reason for better for worse
this is the game that destiny is and i
think the problem is bungie made destiny
not knowing what type of game it was
going to be and they've sort of
transformed it over the year to be this
thing now it's just without a doubt it's
a game as a service game if you look at
their uh term user terms of agreement it
says we are a live game of our content
and it can come and go as they want so
if it's a live game their model has to
match and in a live game you shouldn't
be selling content that you're going to
take away you shouldn't probably have a
subscription service if you're also
selling season passes just doesn't
really make sense and microtransactions
don't really have any
business being in a triple a game where
you pay for a full expansion so like all
of the stuff they're doing together
doesn't make sense they just have to
pick a direction and personally i don't
really care what goes i think
subscription would be a mistake i think
going back to the old way of doing it
and just selling expansions would be a
mistake i think they should pursue the
seasonal model but if they're going to
do that then they need to simplify it
they need to get rid of old stuff and i
think i think again i don't think it's a
malicious thing i don't think bungie or
the the business people are looking at
this like oh i've come up with a brand
new way we can rip off players i think
they honestly just have a really hard
time understanding the game that they're
selling and and figuring out where the
sweet spot is for monetization so i
really think it's that simple yeah you
getting i was just going to say it's
like so the hard part is
if you ask okay so you want to do a 25
subscription model for not subscription
25 season pass are we getting the
stories that we're getting in the
seasons now as like that's your main
story when do you get your witch queen
forsaken when do you get your bigger
moments then that they're trying to
occasionally still have their story arcs
and bigger villains if they're getting
into and again this is a speculation of
like the story stuff that they're doing
now actually getting even better in
which queen and hopefully it does but
again that's where their expansions do
come into play for
a world state is like where do you put a
destination in
like if i bought this season pass for
season 16 i get a whole new destination
but if i get the season pass for season
18
i just get some seasonal content but i
don't i have to go like how that's the
hard part again that's where you that's
that i don't know that stuff is all free
that stuff's all free
the big expansions are the reason people
come and play the game that's how it
works in other live service games like
the big expansion is free all the
players come to play that and then they
sell you other stuff on top of that the
smaller stores and seasons the
additional you know progress bars that
you can fill up to unlock special
weapons and season passes the micro
transactions all that stuff but they
need a base game to draw players too and
that base game should be free which
cranes free every year they drop an
annual release lightfall it's free but
all the stuff on top of that all the
extra content that's that's why they
sell you this is bad that's how they get
you if you want to put it that way but i
i just think like they they still need a
base game like that's not going to
change they can't just never release a
major expansion again and keep expect
their players to like keep paying them
or continue to like people are freaking
out about a dungeon that might cost 10
the season pass for 25 could also be a
hard pill for some people to swallow
sure i was like but but if you but if
you make the main content the meat of
every season free and then the season
pass on top of it is just you know what
i mean like they're they're need if
they're going the live service model
there needs to be a free version of the
game where you get some of the stuff
right and then a premium version of the
game where you get the other stuff so
which queen comes out it's a free game
but the done the dungeon that's
associated with it the raid the end game
content is locked behind season pass
that's what i would expect of a live
service game that's what i haven't
expected they're in a tough spot they
just did a tough spot
they they've they have so many different
models so many different things tied to
so many different systems said light
progression then the constant okay now
we're removing this how is this going to
affect the new player when he comes in
what's his experience you know the
cosmodrome thing which i don't know what
their metrics are as usage and who's
really going there when the new player
experience is coming on the the new
light kind of thing
look i'm not going to sit here act like
it's easy right i'm not going to sit
there and move it but
like y'all said like they've got to come
up with something they've got to come up
with something because currently as it
exists i mean just getting to the point
now it's just like
every time we see a new model or some
new implementation
and they're going to get it they're
going to get it after there's only so
much as great as this game is and i know
when that trailer dropped and we know in
that witch crane trailer job all of us
here going bend the knee and we buying
it with no matter what's going on we
know that however there comes a point
though you keep playing around with this
loyalty and i'm gonna give it to you
teddy you keep
messing with that loyalty that you've
built and accrued and i think they have
been lucky because they've been the last
live service game standing and they've
they've endured when everyone thought
they were gonna die they they've built
up this credit of this undying thing but
you keep playing with with player
satisfaction and and trust
and if if you lose it it's over so i
just want to give it to ted because i
know he had wanted to say some things
and then keep keeping pushing but that's
what i'm saying so
i have
two
two things um
when they talked about content vaulting
initially they gave an example of how a
warmind mission was was bugged or
something and it was affecting like less
than one percent of the whole player
base
and they used that paragraph
uh as justification for like
why they had to remove certain things
because
them editing something or fixing
something else somewhere unrelated to
that would you know affect that mission
negatively and then they had to spend
more resources to do that well here's my
counterpoint
just hire more people you're already
doing it you're already you're already
curating the best people in the industry
i see their hiring process i constantly
see them i do various people from
various disciplines posting about come
work with us they're clearly they've
been staffing up for years now they're
opening a new studio get a dedicated
team
fix that bloating problem that they
discussed and then if you encounter an
issue like that where it affects such a
minuscule amount of players then you
from a business perspective should go
okay it's only affecting a certain
amount of business or it's only
affecting a certain amount of
players it's a small amount uh we can
fix this but the timeline will be
a little bit longer than our usual fixes
and then communicate that like
communicate that so that the few players
that
are affected by this can go okay this
mission is busted for me i'm gonna put
destiny down for a little bit
and ignore it halo's been doing this for
years uh with mass chief collection and
even halo 5 and they've been doing it
with infinite and that game's not even
out yet yeah uh
battlefront 2 did this excellently after
all the backlash and that game
no man's sky this is another example of
that
these companies actually began having
real conversations with their community
versus the the bungie conversation which
is very reactive it's always been
reactive it's never it's never a
proactive discussion with them
and then
my final point
uh
they
the the new light experience
uh they spent a considerable amount of
resources on new light
every year and they tout it um i was at
e3 working e3 when they initially
announced new light and we did all the
exclusive interviews and all that stuff
and
on paper new light is genius and that
was actually announced at free to play
but
at a certain point if you're spending
all these resources to make the game
initially accessible for for players
shouldn't you just
make the game generally accessible so
that it's not this like ultra confusing
experience even for us it's confusing
sometimes like yeah how many times have
one of us had to explain to each other
yeah a random thing in the game that's
that's conflict and we play the game a
lot yeah and so you know joe schmoe who
just picked up the game because it was
free to play on xbox and it was on the
homepage for the weekend
like they're not gonna know that no idea
yeah like and they're not gonna youtube
most people aren't on youtube reddit
twitter yeah they're not checking the
bungie blog or the bonji forums it's
just not them and so
the new light experience
if you're gonna keep the free to play
model the new light experience needs to
be
what what kind of travis is saying it
has to be an actual game like an actual
experience and then you pay for the
extra
the end game stuff or or this or the the
the
beefier season pass like i'm willing to
pay 20 bucks for season pass if that
means i get a raid and a dungeon
uh every season one or the other doesn't
have to be both and then there's an
actual content in me but my counterpoint
to that is let me play all of it at once
that's what's about to ask you don't
don't with your
yeah don't do the same drip feed you
know bs uh where i am doing one triumph
a week because you've limited me to this
single like seasons work on on games as
a service game though
uh
but the thing about fortnite like apex
is
it's a multiplayer experience whereas
destiny is primarily a single player
experience or a cooperative experience i
should say so like the the stuff they're
releasing in seasons for apex or
fortnite it's usually cosmetics or an
event at the end of the season or like
they're building up to an event so you
don't necessarily have to be there for
the whole thing but destiny i want to
experience all of it because it's story
stuff there's right there's world
building there's dialogue there's
there's guns there's a quest there's
actual things that aren't um temporary
like there's things that i can do that
are lasting unlike those other games
um
yeah and so i i just i don't think of
games that have
like the same sort of story content
nothing
yeah there aren't a lot elder scrolls
online has it actually i mean nothing
goes away in that game that's as far as
i know
the the the there there's like events
like in any any game with in-game events
has stuff that goes okay but another
story an event
i i think is different versus like a
seasonal story drop right now
the loss is an event but the more sov
story is a story like it's a campaign
effectively yeah
the way i see it like it's kind of a
i think they view it as alive they don't
because that's how they treat it but
yeah but that's how i see it so but
that's all i got like it's nothing it's
just it's confusing yeah no that was me
i was gonna give it to you and i was
gonna ask you e before i give it to you
it's just that um i know we're trying to
come now i was gonna say for some
solutions like
yeah you're funny what i was saying is
like you know is there a scenario that
can exist
where the destiny content vaulted
campaigns right can be accessed for
these new life or is it just too
confusing with all the systems the
multiplayer the exotics and stuff tied
to this and that like
do you even think there is a proper
solution to that new light situation
that um you know teddy's talking about
also i mean part of it we discussed last
time with regards to
the timeline the fact that they
introduced the timeline would be a way
to at least get some people up to speed
now do they get to experience what we
got to experience go through the story
of the campaign missions
you take a lot of stuff away if you just
say hey here's these cinematics that
kind of explain what went through click
here this was the forsaken story you can
see like kind of a summation or a cliff
notes like inkblot storyboard thing that
we've talked about before and that's a
way to do it but
it does still take away from being in
the moment of like going through hearing
the voice dialogue that happens during
the mission seeing the cutscene that
happens in the right place and is what
teddy's saying is about the story is why
it's so different for destiny is the
seasons are more than just these like
festival of the lost festival lost is
like that is what a lot that is what an
event is for most live service games
yeah some cosmetics it's gonna be
your put on a pretty show that goes
along with a theme i mean you like like
overwatch it's you know it's a free game
and it's got you know your olympics
events and you got skins and stuff you
don't have
overwatch generally they do their like
occasional one-off like youtube videos
for a character but you don't have it
telling like this concurrent story that
goes through seasons while sometimes our
seasons are detached they hopefully are
building to something but the idea is
you're going through and experiencing
a story and it's not meant to be
temporary but unfortunately now the way
the vaulting is working it's making it
very temporary which
makes the new light experience really
rough because you can't be in the like
one of the moments from the red boar no
one's ever gonna get to experience again
the slow walking dramatic music mission
when you jump into destiny you're like
oh cool i got this thing dude just
kicked me off a ship i lost my light and
i'm in a bad place right now and no
one's going to get to experience how red
war didn't actually suck it was a goal
was one thing i was like
that was actually and there was a lot of
missions to it it's got i like that
campaign yeah i really yeah i was like
so
i mean we've beaten this thing to death
so we're going to move on here in a
second but it is
to a point where it's like i mean travis
is saying it's like you know
subscription doesn't make sense and
right now even if it was something they
considered they haven't built enough
like faith within the community and they
don't have a new player experience that
makes sense for that even to be an
option
for
i mean teddy's over here wondering it's
like why
do we have all these disconnected pieces
i was like there's so much going on
it's like i
this is why to bring it all back is why
we wanted destiny 3 because it's so
broken right now like i don't we can't
even between the four of us i don't know
if there's a good solution that any of
us specifically have to say you could do
the seasonal model it's 25 bucks okay
well then you have like is a raid and a
couple dungeons in the seasonal activity
worth 25 now does that come with some
skins
this is free over here how does the
development like there's so many moving
pieces to their current models you guys
said i don't know where it's going to
land i really don't but as i don't want
to keep kind of cycling around the same
train is there anything else you guys
want to add before we go on to
the next piece of this
trap i think for your guys's
conversation about to to all of your
guys's point about preservation of
content which i think every destiny
player wonders about i just think there
needs to be some
separate app like if they're not gonna
if they're not getting stuff and they'll
not with you that's what i was thinking
i think that i i think the vault the
vault could be a service that could that
could be a subscription
yeah like have a
have a have like a separate you know
like private server where some of the
old activities are still alive or that
sort of thing like that makes sense to
me but i i just think that
some people in the destiny community are
afraid to have destiny evolve as a game
they don't want they want it to be what
it has always been which is like a
triple a blockbuster game that kind of
does some stuff that's mmo like but it
never really goes there i think bungie
is being brave and saying all right
we're going to embrace it we're going to
go way more toward the livestream we're
going to push forward and make it an
evolving world and i think that that's
good they should be lauded for that but
they have to do some stuff to make the
model make sense of the players because
right now it feels super exciting and it
feels like they don't they don't know
what they're doing
what model they should pick and i just
think they need to
they just need to get with the times
they need a full commit if they're full
committed to being a live service game
change your model to represent it get
rid of the old blockbuster model of
selling us big expansions especially if
you're going to be taking it away it
makes no sense yeah shout out to tech
real quick said he would pay good money
to be a fly on the wall in the bun in a
bungee board room and i was like that's
the biggest thing because we go back to
is like what is the business decision
and again there's probably a white board
full of like
strings connecting all these pieces and
here's these models these work with
these do we do this
they got the actual savage
whiteboard is for real they just took
that out of their like conference room
what does it mean
exactly a month what did she say yeah so
it's just like it would be
like yeah the bungee board room meetings
the high up executive like those
meetings and again you've got mark and
you've got luke now above thinking about
are we doing movies or
tv shows or other things outside of just
destiny the game there's so much going
on in that studio right now i honestly
can't even imagine but yeah it's like
i'm i'm with travis it's like at this
point it needs
some resolution but i'm also at a
wondering point of like have they built
so many is it so convoluted at this
point they don't even know how to
move out yeah because of because yeah
what could be restrictions in the way
because to what travis was saying is
what i was thinking and i shouted my boy
got bob so he actually said the same
thing he was like if it was technically
possible because again i don't want to
be disrespectful i don't know the back
end but if it was technically possible
to have an
offline downloader of forsaken shout out
to yeah shout out to the sponsor
[Laughter]
forsaken and all the old campaigns so
that if you wanted to do those you could
get it rocking right you know what i'm
saying and you could catch up and then
the current game is what travis would be
talking about which we like is this
ever-evolving ever-changing you know
what's gonna happen but if you want you
know what i'm saying again i i don't
know if it's technically possible
because that would satiate both issues
right the the person who comes back be
like wait a minute okay if i really want
to go back but what if i want to learn
how the crow became recruit what if i
want to learn what gall was and what
that meant to the universe before hey
download the dcv offloader you know it
says offline get that just do it maybe
it doesn't have matchmaking private
service maybe it doesn't have
matchmaking maybe it doesn't have the
rate or whatever but you still got the
core experience that doesn't go away
whereas the new game you got your
seasonal model you get the stuff is
still going on and then they can do
their little vault and push away but i'm
with you e if there was any way to say
let's put it this way let's if if
destiny 3
tiger engine could satiate those needs
i'm all for it blow up the vault again
yeah
let them come blowing up the tower again
or whatever do what you got if they
could if they can i don't know how it is
on the back i will say the one well i'm
gonna say this last thing the one one
time fee they get hit with me with right
now and i pay the 20 in a heartbeat
double my vault space for 20 bucks and
i'm done i could i would do that so fast
you would make so much money off of me
20 bucks don't care i've suggested this
multiple times a separate like app on my
phone or website where i move items that
i want to keep but not necessarily want
to use constantly into that vault and i
would pay money for it like like a cloud
service
like pokemon does for your pokemon right
yeah
come on has a separate uh subscription
service you can pay for to move all your
pokemon there and store them we only pay
like five bucks a month for just uh just
to play stuff
yeah
it's easy dc vault dcv vault off loader
for everything yeah
it was their solution to uh linking
every game so that's that's how you
transfer pokemon from like a certain
generation up because i think anything
below 6th gen there's like a funky path
you have to take but six gen and up can
use the bank so you just use the bank to
go from any game uh back and forth as
long as it's compatible obviously bring
your pokemon with you i i honestly
thought about subscribing to that
because like pokemon's my jam sometimes
like you know when it's hot i'm not one
of those guys
that's just fast and furious in star
wars
yes right okay
and destiny don't forget of course of
course but at this point
i would definitely say we want them to
like
transparency with regards to stuff like
forsaken and the dungeons so
transparency needs to be much more clear
just across the board
some way to help new players have a way
to access
historic content get old experiences so
they can kind of have the full
experience that some of us have
and if it is like a separate thing an
old i don't don't know and then of
course give me that 10 vault charge i'm
down that's all i got to say
i'm with you bro but
now we're kind of into the point of the
current week and before we go too far
into like
the activities of the week i wanted to
get to why my twitter's still exploding
as we're in the middle of this podcast
and hotfix dropped at about noon uh you
know they'll do their thing got a few
fixes in there nothing major
and then shout out to new rad in my
discord he mentioned it's like hey i
think public events are dropping less
pages he checked a couple i went through
i did two heroics and one normal and
they were dropping one page well after
the nerfs that we literally got live in
the middle of the podcast last week
this one was pretty close again with
changes going on and that was the
fastest way to get them
about 210 candy two to three pages per
public event
you know i've done public events in 90
seconds or so and some are about four
minutes but it's the best
one and now granted i threw that tweet
up and oh man the con the replies the
retweets because you get tagged and all
that and i was like i hadn't muted the
conversation just for entertainment
value i should have but it was
entertaining to watch
dmg did actually reply and said hey
they're looking into this did figure out
um shout out to dmg the fact that it was
a bug
um
i
what is on these pages
that is so damn valuable that we can't
get them this fast
well like part of the issue with regard
to the truth of the headless ones so
public events having decreased candy and
spectral pages errant change was
deployed alongside the fix for the candy
spectral pages from nightfalls earlier
today and the issue was last week they
nerfed lake of shadows because some
people could glitch it or you can
honestly run it pretty fast as it is
anyway because lake of shadows is fast
they said they're working on you know a
change to revert the changes to bless
you uh the public events so the public
events was not supposed to happen but
still last week they nerfed expunge
which
theoretically i could run that normally
without going up and over a wall where
things don't spawn i ran it normally in
three and a half minutes
by myself completely solo i could run
that thing in three and a half minutes
and then
um the rathborn hunts
those were being farmed in like you know
one to two minutes fallout had a video
of like if you have a group it could go
even faster and then you still had
public events in there and then the lake
of shadows it's always been an insanely
fast strike and you know they're worried
about people farming it for grand
masters and all those things
at some point that strikes just going to
get stealth like deleted from the game i
think same with you
so you already had the nerfs last week
and then this one happened which you
know sent twitter into just absolute
trash fire which is fine and that was a
bug that's okay
but again this actually takes me back to
what we were talking about before is
they try and do one change to a
nightfall which they shouldn't have
nerfed in the first place and we talked
about that
but then they turn around and then they
break something else a public event
because they tried to do a nightfall
change this goes back to
what
shaky
house of cards kind of question mark
thing
again like a nightfall change breaks
public events dropping spectral pages
like these things and this is
the fact that that actually affected one
versus the other again their code is
there's a lot going on in their game and
we know that it's probably on the edge
of breaking half the time anyway
but it is just weird to see this now the
fact that it's a bug is fine stuff
happens okay
but i just kind of wanted to get
especially teddy as well with regards to
i'm sure you were done with this in the
first day you probably found the
efficient one and you were done but just
your thoughts because you weren't here
last week on the fact that they nerfed
the fastest things and if this would
have been real before actually the patch
is kind of where you're sitting with
this event as is no matter if you got
the pages the 194 pages you have to earn
you still have to do like 16 to 18
haunted sector playlist runs
no matter what so you have that to do
anyway much less those so teddy
so i've been really busy the last couple
weeks and when they announced all this
stuff or when it came out on tuesday i
had just come back from a
a trip and so i was kind of looking at
it and kind of acclimating myself and i
was like all right i'm going to get this
done
uh
over the course of the event i'm just
going to play like really casually
because the last like month and a half
i've only logged in on tuesday to just
do whatever like one or two triumphs i
can do because they're all time gated
and then i don't play and i'll do like
some challenges for xp and that's it
like i've been taking a really nice
break from destiny yep so
uh it was
i think on wednesday night
i had like a four-hour window where i
said all right i've got some time let me
let me do the rathborn farm and as i'm
doing it i'm like this is absolutely
gonna get stuck like the patch isn't sad
we know when they're gonna do it because
yeah because they
they don't like it when you earn any
currency too quickly and then
the following day uh they they reduced
it and thankfully i had already gotten
like most of the pages um but it's just
silly uh i've said this a million times
if i want to play destiny hyper
efficiently
i should not be penalized because little
timmy is upset that i did it faster than
he could because i had more time to do
it that's that's really what it boils
down to is they're always afraid of this
public perception that oh
streamer x
uh
got
he did the thing too quickly and now and
and then the average player is like oh i
don't want to do it now because i've
already seen it that's that's always
what it boils down to all the time i
agree because they want people to play
the event they want people to spend
money and it's a four week event or
three week event whatever whatever it is
so i'm thankful that i got most of it
done otherwise i'd probably be pulling
my hair right now i got all the triumphs
done i hate that they had score for
event triumphs it's really stupid please
make them zero again so i don't have to
do some of them um
however i will point out to their credit
they've made event triumphs less grindy
so i'm happy about that um they're
they're much more streamlined but
uh the event itself like the lost
sectors were cool the first couple times
but i had to do 20 of them for triumph
and uh you hear the same dialogue after
the fifth one and it's uh
yeah it's it's kind of whatever also uh
ibanez talked about this privately uh
you can only do 10 headless ones in the
first five minutes oh my god
yeah oh my god yeah
he told me that yeah when he told me
that i was like not doing it me being
like hyper efficient you know i get my
most time that you've had yeah i was
going to say 90 seconds i saw about
minute 15 the other day
90 seconds to a minute 45 and then
you're just sitting there like
nothing's spawning literally nothing's
happening you just have to wait and then
the boss responds when the timer i'm
like why why doesn't that just auto end
and then the boss spawns yeah if you
wanted to stop it you keep killing me or
just go one or the other don't make it
like force the timer to run out but they
did both wrong like both sides better
so when i was grinding for the pages
what i learned was uh
after getting a perfect run where i
didn't die because if you die i think
you lose uh like one of your stacks
or something like that something makes
you lose a stack of pages
i had a perfect run right and die it
actually caps you out at 15 pages no
matter how many headless ones you killed
wow so to kill if you kill them during
the boss fight if you just ignore the
boss and kill the max amount of headless
ones you can kill it'll cap you at 15.
uh which to me is like why and then and
then the page nerf on top of that and
it's like well
who
who cares the gun is not even that good
that's what i'm saying
like it's it's okay at best it's okay
uh and then you and then you're giving
me two reissued weapons from the last
two years of this event yeah
honestly i would have taken the the
infinite forest again at this point like
just just give me that again like that
at least at least that was like
you know
okay
if you were doing something else but
this is just
it's
badly designed event very eververse
focused uh
festival the costs we've said it over
the years i remember that
yeah did any of you guys buy the dino
armor
i bought it for paying attention
yeah yeah i'm spending money on an event
i'm gonna get the metrics because uh my
information my my contribution to this
topic could be very short i'm with teddy
um i made a conscious decision to say
i'm not doing this
i'm not i'm just i'm not after
i i didn't start on the tuesday it
debuted
and i'm like all right my plan was just
scheduling thing life was in the way so
i said thursday i'm gonna go in and do
all this stuff right
then he tells me about
the the the um what you call it the old
you can't do the special thing
yo they nerfed this yo if you do the
headless now you gotta wait
and it's like oh
now it's a candy nerf
then i always look at
the reward
why am i going to be in here
yeah it's like i've never liked festival
to be honest and then that was already
jumped so i'm like all right if they got
a good you know i'm looking at the
archetype i'm like it's okay
you know i looked at the roles it's
really it's lincoln green i'm like this
is literally
lincoln green and you finessing me for
lincoln green like i'm not doing it for
lincoln green i'm sorry i love i love
you devon but i'm not doing it
they added new perks on it that weren't
available when lincoln green was around
and the combinations are really bad as
well and there's like only one though
why are you saying it like a jewish
grandmother
perks on it
you can play
you never call anymore teddy
i'm sorry grandma i'm not doing it i'm
not i'm not doing the homework i'm not
doing the chores this week grandma no
no i'm not sorry i did i did it for that
thank you so i'm just like i'm out i'm
out like i remember forte be had at a
conversation there was one event i
forgot i think it was dawning one year
he was like i'm not doing that and this
was the one i'm like no i'm not doing
this
and on top of it is that i've already
done most of the stuffs i need i got my
vags i got most of the gog roll weapons
i farm my umbrellas with the the triple
focusing you know i did that the other
thing those sucked by the way can i call
that out it's really yeah the tier three
umbrellas this i've got more in the like
50s
mid 50s
below 60 for every one of them and i'm
like you can even do you can even do the
ghost like you know give you at least 10
intellect and then i pick a recovery and
i literally get like 11 intellect 22
recovery and that's where everything
else is like two six two two four and
i'm like what the
this is not supposed to be this crap
it's 600 of this currency that i farm
now and it's just like you already have
the world of rng stats yeah you already
have multiple slots that it can go in
and then you're gonna tell me it's like
trash in the first no
yeah i'm not doing it and like i said
like you know between that
obviously
trials is honestly why i log in you know
if dj and the crew hit me sentenced in
the crew iron banner comes in you're
like oh man yeah i'm not doing grand
masters i'm not i got shadow price i got
what i got like i'm good like you know
what it was the incentive dropped for me
substantially
once e
the story was on this halt yeah we got
the mid-season walking dead fiasco you
know come back the season concludes this
season continues come see the finale in
two months all right i'll see y'all with
saboteur's back [ __ ] will tune in when
savage through returns
it's not it's not on on hold cog okay
it's it's in stasis it got the aramis
effect okay
it's in the destiny content vault for a
couple months yeah it's
marinating
i get it it's long long season
i get it
it's literally so what cog said is yo
got these other games i didn't boot it
up with disco elysium i'm hitting the
back so good oh my god it's amazing oh
my god i've heard that game's amazing i
need to do it i've never played bro i'm
doing are you playing the thinker the
i'm doing intelligence for and the other
one the intellectual stuff four and four
strength about three motorix motorix low
motorix are low
but man that game was the greatest build
you did yeah i did the custom that
game's the greatest customer i mean the
greatest voice acted game for every
single npc with this new final cut
edition oh i'm thrilled i'm having a
ball you know what when i when i
reviewed it it didn't have voice acting
oh yeah because the original version
didn't so i
now no i'm playing it on xbox now
it's good and it's bad it's it's good
because the voice acting is is quite
charming but also like i had voices in
my head oh what it was going to be yeah
it's a little weird yeah yeah but i i
advise
yeah
so just that's how i'm doing it that's
how i'm looking at this take care of
what i got to take to my game wise
i'll help the clan if they need
something shout out you know like i said
dj sending the crew but yo we're gonna
run i think the only thing i haven't
done is they trying to get me 1k voices
because 1k is so good with the with
particle deconstructed this season and i
don't have 1k so we you know we'll be
doing that but other than that i'm
chilling bro i'm just i'm not doing that
stuff man i'm just not but
i was gonna say travis first because i
got a nice little segway i'm gonna cheat
my way into
travis
yeah
what do you want are you are you done
with like festival did you do it on
just where you have a festival before i
go to my next topic
destiny what do you want from me i need
you to view it for a couple minutes i
gotta step up no i'm just kidding that
was hilarious
what do you want from me what are you
doing
no that that was actually not a question
for you i was speaking directly to
bungie oh okay um no i i sorry i was i
was responding to a comment i forgot
what we were talking about um
yeah festival the lost i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna get all the pages i'm gonna
get do the candy to get all the masks um
just so that i can
you know for me because i play destiny
so i can talk on the show and cover it
for ign and all that stuff like i feel
like i an obligation to put myself
through the pain just so that i can feel
like i understand
what's going on and if you take a break
from festival of the lost and you don't
feel all that pain you don't really
understand the turmoil and the suffering
that they're bringing that they're
carrying when they go and do the destiny
30th anniversary
and i feel like it's important so i'm
gonna do it but i've basically done no
grinding because i've been working on
the ign reviews recently and uh
i'm like i've i've gotten maybe like 70
pages 80 pages so no thing but i've got
a lot more to go and i got a lot more
candy to grind and unfortunately
they nerfed the uh
the public events which is how i was
doing the grind i was grinding public
events just because it's kind of
something i can do with my brain off
listen to stand-up comedy or watch a
show or whatever while i'm doing that
and uh now i'm not gonna be doing that
for one page so we'll see if they fix
that to your strike playlist to level up
your uh vanguard rank
so you can get your ascendancy or this
your ascendancy ornament
you're never going to do that i'm not
going to play strikes i would rather die
just go play crucible
yeah i guess i'll play crucible i really
don't know what my plan is now i'll see
if they fix it one thing that really
bothered me with this is that
they
they
are
patching so quickly all of these sources
that you could easily grind
but then they're not fixing all of the
negative feedback like the the
artificial cap on only killing 10
headless ones and then having to wait
around like those are clear
issues with the with the event that they
probably should have fixed in the first
round and those ones are getting left in
even though there has been a lot of
complaining about that stuff publicly on
reddit and twitter and i'm just like it
just it feels really weird when they fix
like the exploits but then they don't
have a big problem yeah but but to try
to get stuff about it
this is another i'm starting to tell you
i would trap there because that's
another reason what i was even thinking
about i was like you know what i need to
at least see the event going there
and it's like they're so quick with the
nerfs i'm like it's it feels more
egregious
this event
like the candy the thing the pages and
i'm just like why are they this
aggressive is it that much of a drought
that we cannot
okay
right now
none of you guys played queen's wrath
oh yeah 48 hours in on hour 49 they were
like oh you're getting a seven shards
and energies too fast we're nerfing this
event that was two days into that and
i think vlog had not even been released
at that point yet or maybe it was
released
i don't think it was like it hadn't been
released there was literally nothing you
could use them for except for guns but
nobody was had the materials through
that anyway because you weren't running
around the cosmodrome or venus for 10
hours to get the mats you know yeah spin
metal
they've been doing this from the
beginning when any any time
any type of there's a currency that's
too quick or whatever they're just like
nope and then any negative anything that
actually affects the player negatively
they're like uh we'll fix it in the in
the quarterly patch mm-hmm they've
they're always done this
it's oh how they are
yeah it's it's yeah it's just i just
like every time i had a little incentive
to try
and then when i saw e tweet i was like
i'm good i'm good yeah i'm good i hear
you man i hear you i would not recommend
it like i'm i'm the worst advocate for
destiny like every other podcast i'm on
that's not about destiny whenever they
ask me like what should i do if i want
to get into destiny i'm like don't don't
do it
i love that game it brings me a lot of
joy but if you if you aren't playing it
right now like just don't play it like
that that's what i tell people when they
ask me i'm like don't play it just don't
yeah and that's the hard part right now
is like
they do these types of things they
nerf these few moments and then you also
see like what is the new player
experience like how do you recommend
this to somebody who's the people who
already like you know stockholm syndrome
we're just we're locked in like they've
got us but it's like if they want to
grow their player base they're not doing
the things that are going to help that
long term
the problem is they're enabled right now
and i've said this before the numbers
are good engagement's up
look at i was shocked trials
we'll get to it
we'll get the thing about it is like i'm
looking at i always look at that metric
games played and they are up there they
are up there they just dropped i know
we're going to talk about the um
in the 12 with the whole you know uh
which i was shocked the game passed pc
version right um you know
i think the problem is it's hard to talk
to someone when the money's coming in
and the engagement's up
it's harder
they're more complex they're more
compassionate post curse of osiris when
that engages her low and people people
are still spongy some at times
yeah they wait right now it's hard to
hear get a budget you don't say it when
when things are looking good that's my
concern right now things are still doing
well
that's why i hope xbox is always second
in the video game ecosystem because i
like xbox better when they're not the
leader of the year yeah just like
every time a new console launch comes
out i'm like man i hope they don't beat
playstation
you know what that dom
i want the underdog microsoft that's
what i want i was like i've been
watching like pc hardware space for so
long it's like nvidia has been sitting
there intel's been stagnant and now you
see amd finally like even putting
pressure on intel may actually sound
like it might come back with alder lake
and actually swing pretty hard but it's
like now it's finally to a point where
that competition's there it's like same
thing in this
and everything else it's like and that's
not coming back
it's going to take us five years
it's gonna take them at least five years
to maybe
uh catch over beating like amd has such
a commanding lead now oh i mean things
just been stagnating for something yeah
i was like they do but it's like no
almost like and then
just it's good to see at least them
pushing each other it's kind of all i'm
saying it's at a point where they are
competition competition yeah that's
always right yeah absolutely one thing
that's
awesome i will say one thing that's not
good is rewards versus difficulty in
this game and i got to talk about this
one because let's go now that i've done
legend shattered realm breaking what i'm
missing
you're missing a painful headache for
not a whole damn bit of much of anything
what's the rewards
no what rewards okay yeah
there's no unique rewards for the hard
version
you know you got your basic chest and
you got your 100 currency chest
you get an extra 100 currency chest
all i got was literally an extra i got
one fractalthis from that one and i got
a second one from the bonus chest after
the headache and the deaths and the like
resets that we had from running out of
time and
not even the double perk ones no
they not even giving you nope not even
tier three rewards
continue
supposedly supposedly from the legend
shattered realm that's what they said
last week they're supposed to be
dropping high stat armor
i looked at the only two pieces of armor
that dropped
one was 56 and one was 57 so it's like
if you think that's high stats you're
full of it
where's the stealth four nine roll
you know
49. that's worth the time
shout out to the disco i am
so there's a triumph that's part of the
title that is you have to do each shot
of realm legendary yeah version and you
don't have to do them solo but last week
i was like no one's on i'm just going to
do the solo i got like an hour to kill
it's not going to take me an hour to do
the solo
hour and a half later because of that
second encounter that's like an
encounter as a bear that's not going to
kill a bear a nightmare yeah wow because
the the the chiefs and captions that
throw the oh it's so much falls out yeah
but but anyway so we'll cover in a
second i'm not doing it for the reward
i'm not doing it for the work what you
do
yes yes yes i don't i don't care what
they were but it'd be nice to get
rewarded for my hour and a half of
suffering during this terrible
experience i get to the end
and i get an r i get a chess piece and
i'm like all right just let's see what
we're working with my chest pieces are
actually the weakest of my all my armor
pieces i only have 64 macs that i like
in that yeah
you
know so so the chest piece drops and i'm
looking at it and i'm like huh
49 huh that's
that's what i get for an hour and a half
of this
nope and then uh this week we did an
asteroid bro i i i smudged together uh
a barely cohesive team of my friends the
people that were willing to boot up
destiny and yeah it was astral wasn't
hard by any means like we probably could
have five-manned it or four manned it
but like okay you get to get to the end
and it's just chess
two chests you gotta pay for you know
there's the og currency the currency one
you gotta pay for and there's a new one
you can pay for and then there's the one
that's like free
uh and nothing it's just it's just
another drop
like that's it and you know
no extra perks no nothing so yeah last
week was debris of dreams that's the
scoring one
so you know have you've done at least
the shadow realm you've seen them all
right cog
yeah i've seen yeah i've done all the
shadows okay all of them yeah yeah those
are amazing those are amazing so debris
of dreams the one with the score and you
kind of got the first ones in the bid
kind of like silo thing aaron you got
the little raised platform that one's
all solar guys and then screams coming
in
whenever time so you're still learning
that one trying with no radar by the way
on either of these
second beacon is the it's the arc
chieftains that the little bouncing ark
balls that they shoot i swear they're
like magnetic pinballs in that entire
friggin arena they go everywhere and
somehow all go after you it doesn't
really matter how much they're going
around and if the abominations saw you
at any point it was like zap dead you
have to delete those on spawn like the
abominations the champions you delete
them on spawn or you may as well kiss
your butt goodbye that's the one thing i
did in my videos like
when you hear that spawn around these
percentages stand here delete them then
you can try and survive the rest
otherwise you are totally screwed
this week
the beacons weren't too bad per se the
first two because you got a little more
space to work
you've got one wall that you can just
kind of hide behind
um but then the third one you've got
like an invisible barrier and basically
you've got a bunch of these arc nights
with like the solar triple shot
crossbows going everywhere you've got
the boss who's a knight but can cast the
like painful bubble of blackness oh like
the wizard is tough yeah but he's just
roaming around i am nowhere around
chasing you i'm nowhere in visible sight
bubble can't even see me over here
bubble like just hitting me with that
thing all over so i'm just like jump up
peak shoot these couple guys jump down
here jump up shoot these guys jump down
here
but it's like yeah i was like i went
through that ran it i think i ended up
beating it like three different times
because i was trying different loadouts
i actually ran through corsair's wrath
for my heavy so that's like a solar
linear fusion i ran with like the number
um just a arc auto rifle because every
one of those shields is arc and actually
i'm going to use an arbalest for
entertainment value just like get the
bonus from uh particle deconstructor i
did another one with borealis borealis
is actually probably the smoother choice
i would say but like either way you're
actually messing around with like what
loadout's gonna work i gotta kill these
there's a bunch of shields got some
champions to manage and yeah you get
done and it's like i saw the arm and i'm
going man this
and that's kind of one thing i wanted to
basically discuss is like 11 legendary
activities and rewards because you go
through
and i don't know if people feel the same
way about vault of glass but i've heard
master vaults kind of in a similar state
of like your effort of going through
vault versus what you're getting
and this is just kind of what makes me
wonder when it comes to somebody
mentioned it probably in a comment or
something is like is this what we're
gonna get in the legendary campaign
next year with witch queen are you gonna
go through and do this legendary
campaign and then get a 56 piece of
armor
and you're like why did i just beat
myself through this like hard mission
and jumped up the difficulty
and a lot of where destiny is at right
now for me and i just wanted to kind of
get you guys take on this one is
the
juice is typically not worth the squeeze
in the harder stuff
trials is the different animal it's like
i'm not really putting that in there but
a lot of the pve higher difficulty items
most of the time the juice is worth like
a triumph and a little pat on the back
but your in-game rewards typically are
not much like even newrat said like your
prime engrams are one of the best rays
for decent stats the random thing you
get in the middle of who knows what
versus doing this difficult activity and
i have
four class items for my titan they're
master worked i don't need to see a
class item for the next four and a half
months ever i don't need a blue i don't
need a legendary i don't need a class
item for the next four months but much
less anything else whether it's like
guns with double perks we don't get many
of those
so i wanted to ask you guys just where
you are you worried about the future do
you hope that's something they changed
do you feel them talking out of my butt
here were you guys on it like juice
worth the screen squeeze difficulty
versus rewards where are you guys at on
all this because just because it hit me
with like legend astral alignment was
like i got people on stream i'm live
pulled enough of them in thanks to cross
play and we did it but it was like you
know we failed a couple
um
ran out of time on kind of each
encounter then we ended i think we did
end up getting the boss because there
was no time but we ran out of time on
each encounter once and then we got
through it we didn't get full wiped but
still you go through all of that and
it's like 20 25 minutes later and i got
two shotguns
so it's just i wanted to see where you
guys were all at on that
let's talk to uh trev of resident pve
expert that's me
you know me
pvp takes no skills all right yeah let's
do it let's do a long run
uh
i
i have always thought that the endgame
pve activities weren't worth the the rub
except raids i mean and dungeons like if
they have unique loot or
you know to me a pve event has to be
worth
it has to be a means to an end it's
crazy that these events the idea of them
actually being fun is completely off the
table we're all talking about what
incentive are you going to give me to go
through these and that's like not the
not a great starting off point i was
like all right i already don't want to
do this all right so there we go that's
like that's like that's like the part of
the premise how are you going to
convince me that i should do it and as
soon as i get into the
doing stuff i don't want to do in
destiny i'm i'm like out most of the
time because i like i like to like
destiny i like enjoying destiny and when
i have to do these events my my opinion
quickly becomes okay no now i no longer
having fun and don't like this game
anymore so i try to minimize how much
that i experience but i i 100 agree for
people like you who either are
masochistic or for some reason do and
you're not wrong like that yeah
yeah i just think like if that's if
that's what you're into they should sure
as hell reward you guys because like
you're doing god's work or something uh
but it doesn't
like you know
the grandmaster nightfalls are like
almost worth it almost the i don't
really consider those events fun just
because they're like hey do you want to
do the same strike you already did but
this time for some reason drags kill you
like no not at all that sounds terrible
yeah well we're at least going to give
you some rewards for doing it that makes
sense to me but uh i honestly just think
pve end game you guys should have your
own
you should have your own trials like
there should be some there should be
some content that's
exclusive to the end game experience
right where there's not an accessible
version and then an inaccessible version
because the only way that that's going
to be fun is if it's not a carbon copy
of something that already exists right
like if you're just doing a version of a
raid but it's super hard
that's not super fun but if you're doing
a
separate dungeon that only exists in a
super hard mode then
i think that there's more incentive
there and
that's sort of the problem with destiny
is they're not really willing to do that
they don't want to lock anything behind
an ultra challenging experience because
of accessibility reasons and i i don't
think you're ever going to get that so
if you're stuck with playing
re-treaded content that's artificially
harder they should
absolutely be rewarding you guys and i
don't think that they've ever been good
at doing that so
teddy
uh yeah i basically agree with most of
that um i think i've talked about this
before but in destiny 1 there was this
major problem of the rich got richer
because you were getting so your gear
was so good that you were able to
effectively do
the endgame activities much easier
whether it was pvp or raids in that game
and i think destiny 2 they absolutely
have been like no that's never going
gonna happen again which is why every
hard mode or prestige mode or whatever
it's the rewards are never quite
adequate it's always just like a triumph
or a title
which is their way of saying well there
is a reason to do it but it's not the
loot reason to do it and i think for me
that's just wrong because i want to be
challenged in destiny like i like
certain grandmasters if they're
challenging some of them are just
ridiculous and
i don't think they actually play tested
uh the ones that are just absurdly
difficult but like
grandmasters i would say actually are in
a pretty good place to counter you um
they just issued a patch where it's 100
chance to get uh the gun now for the
week but but here's the problem now
there's multiple guns per week so you
can't actually like target farm which is
which is slowly but at least you're
guaranteed the gun right whereas before
you go
even even with that
even without that like the rewards for
grandmasters
i would say they've definitely got a
positive direction for that i think
raids definitely need some work
um
vog
master vlog started off on a poor
note but they i think they did it pretty
smartly now with how you only get armor
um
on master and then and then the
challenges are what give you the weapons
uh for master and then you can and then
the system they have at the end of the
raid i think is also really smart um
but other aspects of the game like like
you said like if there was a dungeon
that was exclusively this is a hard
dungeon and you have to pay for it i'm
okay with that
or or if it was free either way like
either either model it doesn't matter
because i just want to like
not to like pat myself back i'm a god in
destiny like my character is a god not
me as a player but like my character is
absolutely
my
i can i can put on
what's what's like a really bad gun
what about just an exclusive strike like
it doesn't even have to be a dungeon if
they made a strike and they created it
behind grand master that would be huge
i would play
right i i sneeze on you actually i have
to get new strikes that's
yeah well that's exactly that's the
problem so like there needs to be not
only does it need to be content that is
challenging but the rewards
uh should always be reflected but but
destiny's just never been that from the
very beginning that's why that's why we
have this problem of what is the
incentive why do you want me to do this
because from the very beginning
destiny's had that problem of why i
don't want to do this this is pointless
why am i running in circles for four
hours to upgrade one gun or why do i why
am i going to make the content
compelling man you know
yeah what's up guys they've never have
this real quick real quickly take care
that you just talked about me and and
that's why
i like vlog right because at the end of
the day
i'm like if i do it
i get vex and i like the effects like
the fact low-key vex is the best thing
ever
right because it's like it's real it's
worth the reward but december the 30th
anniversary i don't know what's going on
my fun's over my fun's over to so but i
just like the idea that i did the
hardest thing in the game right
allegedly supposedly you got it by rng
oh oh here we go don't you start i'll be
nice i'm being that we're not doing this
two weeks ago i know but at the end
it is rng and you know he knows i agree
with him on a fundamental level but at
the end of the day it's just like it
should be the most powerful thing and it
should incentivize people to be like yo
i'm getting killed by this thing where
did you get that oh vog let me get my
behind in there to get that and do the
hard content but if you're giving me
shadow price and
the comedian oh i could care less about
the comedian the hot what's the matter
i got one of those with like
tracking and something reasonable and
i'm like good
got one yeah high head with stability
plus plus two mod no
no
i'm not going through all of that you
gotta give me that compelling and it
puts us back in that spot where we
talked about with the pinnacle rewards
which they clearly don't want to go back
to you they clearly keep doing
everything in their power to not do it
and i'm with you
horizontal how many horizontal weapons
are we going to get
like there's not a whole lot of
verticality with regards to the words in
the game it's like everything is meant
to be close to balanced for
pvp because you can take your raid vex
and you can
take that over into pvp and they got to
make sure that's not too powerful or
doesn't feel completely different from
pve versus pvp
and i still pvp isn't even balanced as
well i was like pvp isn't that like yeah
i was like that's never going to be
perfect and it's like
at some point
again as you said is a grand master for
me it's like i see somebody like ek i
see swifty who i'm actually working on
getting on the show
um
different people run these things he's
done a thousand grand masters you guys
saw ek's golden vault i mean these
people do it just because like they're
doing carries and stuff and they're you
know service streamers and more power to
them they're doing awesome stuff cool
but i was like is there any real benefit
to a normal person to go and run
it's like you know i you get a gun that
has an adept possible perk you get a
smidge more here as you said it's a
smidge more there and they can't go they
can't go too over the top and they need
to at that there's a point where they
have to at some point at least in the
pve side because i mean shout out to new
world because like yeah i'm chopping
down a thousand trees i can still wander
through a level six wolf as a level 33
and just be like doo doo doo bam doo doo
and it's like you run around in patrol
and you still gotta shoot a thrall you
know a couple times or whatever
there are moments you just
you don't ever get something that really
stands out like the perks set bonuses
anything that really can make you better
in pve
versus combatants you could throw that
on literally
all these extra things you want to do
but at some point
for me it's like as you said if i'm
gonna beat my head for an hour and a
half and then i get a 49 chest that's
where you're like i'm going to go see a
movie i'm going to shut it down right
now i'm going to go pick up a different
game when i get my i'm like
i got an email about my monitor i've
been waiting on forever it's like couple
weeks out hopefully i'm almost there
when that comes in i'm like i want to
see ratchet and clank in 4k death
stranding with dlss like there are so
many things just like pulling at me to
say finally i'm like uh-uh like i don't
and for me like
if i was good enough to carry people
through grand masters that'd be one
thing but even that it's like that's
something i don't really want to do
because even at that point it's like all
they're doing is like hey the golden
vault or the thousand but you don't they
don't get
better than anybody else for doing that
relatively they have efficient loadouts
like teddy's got 64 stats on anything
but is there are you are you ever going
to get a piece of armor
that's going to make you noticeably
better you might get one more better set
here one more anything else like the
fact that
you know class items you're like you're
good forever you probably have been for
a very long time you'd be like oh i got
four just make it stay sit max it out
open done with class items again you
were done as soon as stasis armor came
into the game in probably about
10 clicks however long it took you to
max a new one out and you were done and
that's
that's the hard part is
i want
like witch queen to work on the rewards
because they're talking about hey here's
all the new weapon crafting and this
type of stuff like if it's still just
going to be hey here's your lincoln
green that's reskinned and you can craft
to put a couple of optimal perks in
there
but it's like is the effort gonna be
worth it to go through crafting who
knows what the parts crafting grind is
going to be how many more currencies
we're going to have
like how how limited we are going to
have yeah like
like one weapon a week or if you're
going to craft a piece of armor you're
going to need to go do 10 grand masters
and spend all your shirt like i don't
know what it's going to be like but i'm
still worried of like the time the juice
is
does not feel like it's not going to be
worth the squeeze unless they change
something and that's kind of where
i mean the armor keeps i've asked for
armor 3.0 forever and ever but it's just
like every soft on the cmr can like
delete delete delete i never need to see
one of these in that slot again and that
just doesn't seem right at all so
if the uh if the armor synthesis or
armor transmog
kind of structures anything to go by i'm
very worried about uh crafting yeah
because
you know there's going to be at least
two currencies of some sort they said
you can like re recraft it to like
upgrade it and so that's my mind
there's recipes
um that you have to unlock and like
different levels of recipes and stuff so
like
it's just it it's got like and for me
personally like in order for me to use a
different piece of gear it has to be
better than the thing i already have and
i have
everything like whatever god rule i i
probably have it my armors my armor i
need to respect some stuff because i
haven't really been playing actively but
like there's no reason for me to i can
still go to master vlog or gm with my
same load i've been using for six months
and i'm still gonna wreck it it just it
doesn't matter and i want them to do so
what if it's like the um the the the
easy bake look we got the cookies and we
gonna bake it up we're gonna do the i
wish i was something
we gonna bake up our crafting go get all
these materials what is that then you're
gonna be out there doing like spin metal
loops just to try and get your crafting
materials again
explosive touch
yeah that's one yeah in a perfect world
whatever crafting is uh
the materials need to drop
as i'm playing the game like i don't i
don't want to go pick up a bounty i
don't want to go do another activity i
don't like it just needs to be
me shoot things thing drops material
well even went to the crafting table
i haven't forgot this when we were
talking about festivals like when you
talk about currencies why do i have to
earn pages in one place to turn them
into another page in another it's like
when i was thinking about travis and
like the currencies i was like why do i
have to go earn 194 pages over here is
that not enough for me to go play all
your normal activities
then you got to turn the currency into
another currency and then you got to
take that currency and put it into a
podium
and then you can read your book the wife
come out with the law did he come out
with the video yet with all the law
pages what it being oh the reason why
the it's like the reason why the
headless ones exist
it kind of goes through i was listening
to somebody talk about it there's like
it's glitched in canon reason yeah yeah
it's like glint kind of talking about
his multiple different speculations as
to why the headless ones actually exist
and then kind of if you put some of the
pieces together you get an idea of
milan's i think where i heard it because
he was talking about it on tcp so i
think i heard that but
yeah mylan did one if you want to hear
but yeah the dec that's that's what it
is you go through and do all of that
just go listen to milo's video in 20
minutes and save yourself hours of
grinding you're dude
man i'm glad i didn't before they nerfed
it oh my god i didn't teddy so i'm in
for the pain
bad for crucible though this is why i'm
the working man's destiny player you
know i'm gonna feel the pain that they
all feel and i'm gonna understand it you
know what i mean
god bless you god bless your service
here's the thing i just want to say one
thing even though i'm not qualified to
talk about this at all because i don't
care about endgame
we're all talking about the reward loop
and i agree it needs to work i agree
like you guys need reasons to play it
pvp does too if this is where you're
going
one hundred percent yeah whatever
percent
but wouldn't it wouldn't it be crazy
if you actually wanted to play and game
pve activities
wouldn't it be interesting if the
content itself is why you engaged rather
than the reward
through
always yeah my problem with pve is like
the reason raids work in my opinion
isn't because they give good loot that's
part of it but the main thing is that
doing a raid is fun
yeah it's right there doing it
it's a unique experience doing a dungeon
is fun
in the dungeons that didn't have
remember the first dungeon they did the
loot wasn't really good
they had like a non-exclusive they
didn't really have an armor set or
anything attached to it it wasn't very
good but the content made me want to
play it and not just once too i played
it a few weeks because i was just having
fun doing that and i just wish that pve
end game activities were fun because
that has been always why i said no to
them
no just not fun i don't want to redo the
same strikes
already you nailed it already it should
have been it should be unique strikes
that only you could do when that comes
up like that's it
yeah or maybe they're maybe they're
existing strikes but they have different
lore attached to them or a different
final boss or there's something
different about them that makes you want
to like
yeah diverging paths or separate
dialogue if there was just something in
there that because i would be
100 doing
the astral alignment and all that stuff
if there were some mara monologues or a
cut scene that unlocked if you made it
to the end of all three of the different
shattered realms like something like
that but they just never i think i feel
like they're afraid to do it because
they don't want to lock content behind
stuff that most players won't be able to
access and so i think that as long as
they take that accessibility approach
these end game activities are always
going to suffer
right that's my validity
doesn't have to get richer if they don't
make it about rewards and they make it
about content or
a cut scene or some extra lore and i
think the reason they don't do that is
because they don't want to lock that
behind
yeah they don't want to actually just
lock in the wall
i think they need to rip that band-aid
off they need to rip it off and just let
people
let people have fun give them a reason
to do it but i was like i mean you joked
i was literally like
when it comes to me doing some of the
stuff that i do solo it's like you joke
that i'm masochistic it's like a hundred
percent at times from doing mega man 3
when i was a crazy when i was a kid
trying to go through and figure out
those like you know you only get a
couple lives you start the whole thing
over it's like and you learn and it's
skill mastery but that's like that's why
i like souls games now is because you
are rewarded in some different way but
you're rewarded in the mastery and when
you talk about grand master
that's not so much i mean okay not to
say that like ek knows like okay this is
here use this weapon shoot [ __ ] like
there is some mastery to it but it
doesn't feel the same
to me at least and teddy you might be
able to like
a souls game level of mastery and maybe
it's just a different type
versus like a team doing a grand master
doesn't feel the same of like me
understanding like um a like a boss's
move set and then i can learn to dodge
versus
you know sit in this corner and do this
like i watch the esoteric i was like oh
man he soloed exodus crash i'm like
probably took some effort to get here
but what was the boss sit behind this
one area cheese sit in a well as a
warlock and just constantly and like
solutions feel cheesy in destiny in the
end game rather than in dark souls where
it's like i feel like i'm learning and
getting better you don't feel better
this is why i was poking fun at you last
week of like what are pv or two weeks
ago what are pve players actually good
at is because like in pve it the
solution is always like cheese
or do this cheese and that to me doesn't
feel like i i don't look at a pve player
when i see a really good pve player in
dark souls i'm like that guy like
practiced and like learned attack
patterns and all that stuff and there's
just none of that nuance in pve and
destiny and so that's why i sort of roll
my eyes when i look at like the pve try
hard so i'm like but what are you like
good at you're good at like knowing when
to like use your super and then like
chain orbs so you can like keep a shield
up forever and it just it it's kind of
like
you know i mean
what i do respect about i hear you guys
right but what i do respect about it is
i like the creativity in loadout
discovery for efficiency i think that is
cool because sometimes i'll watch e i
watch you know esso and obviously teddy
you're one of those guys like and shout
out to welcome scream like sometimes
there's like older stuff that we would
deem useless because we haven't used it
a long while and then you realize it has
a great you know effectiveness with this
certain level of content based on the
shields based on the setup of the thing
but i understand what you're saying from
like a pure skill ceiling yeah
yeah i know where you're going with that
i just like that wow creatively
sometimes i'm like oh wow i could have
dust off this uh controversy hold on
here for to deal with this or you know
just different things but i understand
what you say it's a different i don't
look at it as a skill base that i looked
at it as a different type of challenge
but i do respect though i got i got it i
got to hold my man down speed runner do
i do respect the soloist
the soloist is a different beast i was
actually gonna say that too about even
like i mean it is because i'm sitting
there i'm like okay so it's like as you
guys were saying that i was kind of
taking myself like back for a second i
was like you know i did the solo on
debris of dreams and as teddy mentioned
that second beak and i'm like okay i
gotta figure out you're gonna spawn here
i wiped okay i need to like kick off the
beacon be over here hit the arc shields
run to the back of the room and granted
it felt like a little of the cheese is
hanging in the back of the room so
you're a little safe so there's a little
cheesy feel to it but also it's like i
know when i'm sitting there like 30 or
so the first two guys are gonna spawn i
gotta make sure i nuke those and then it
does feel like a chicken with my head
cough so there's times i feel like
there's skill of like hey these guys are
gonna spawn here i gotta make sure i tag
them right and quick um to hit these
guys in this order to do those things so
is there
skill to it yes but it's like sometimes
like
the skill that you do get to like learn
and understand the encounter and you get
the loadouts which is a thing because i
pulled up borealis for this week and i
was like that actually does feel good i
cannot tell you the last time i used
that weapon i was like it's a sniper it
lets me switch it gives me some options
and actually kind of works out so much
better yeah so it's like that was one of
those random ones that actually did
count for that
but on the other side it was also
sometimes i still feel like and then i
got to the third beacon and once again
i'm kind of in the i understand what i
have to do
but i was like i kind of feel like i
have to be a chicken with my head cut
off at times just to get through it like
jump up here ding ding oh this one thing
is like shooting me from over here so i
got to go back into cover and it's like
there is a safety of like watching the
health bar and playing that but it's
like when you get up to like if they did
like a master level and i peaked wrong
i'm gonna get one hit
that's the point where it does kind of
bug me there's just too much randomness
right yeah and it's not just like hey if
i play a souls guy and it's like i get
smashed by a giant axe that kills me in
two hits
if i get hit once it's on me to make
sure i don't screw up again either i get
a healing or i play smart and i play
safe and cautious and you can play
almost as safe and cautious as you can
and sometimes i feel like when you get
to the highest difficulties that's why
gm's at some point i'll get into those
but i still just really haven't because
of how they feel
in that kind of cheesy nature of like
the artificial difficulties the wrong
word but you do have very little margins
for error and you do unlike some dark
souls bosses so i'm like i know i'm kind
of talking myself in the circle but it's
like i'm really looking forward to elden
ring
and i know how those fights are gonna
feel and it's like i played grime i
played death store like multiple
different games with like
all those feels involved and something
about destiny never quite has that same
feel of like i feel like when i was
playing you know the final boss and
death story like that guy
there's a lot of pieces i'm like that is
a long fight and you finally get to the
end same thing with the end of grime
both of those like but i kind of like i
watched i learned okay i know this is
coming and it just doesn't quite hit the
same for me and i don't know if i can
put my finger on why i guess i think i
think it's uh they lack mechanics and
like timing stuff like you don't there's
no parry in destiny there's no like all
right when he does this attack i'm gonna
respond to this and it's all just very
like straightforward i shoot him and i
try to not get shot like if that's if
that's the extent of the of the like
combat it's never gonna reach the level
where you're like all right it's about
skill and like learning cause yeah like
i said i respect somebody who like can
speed run dark souls but in destiny it's
always felt like okay so you're good at
like exploiting weapons or like figuring
out different builds that like are
basically just amount to you kind of
experimenting it's just it's very
different and i think i think bungie has
always been afraid of adding like
mechanics or timing based stuff because
it's a it's a accessibility barrier they
don't want that in their game they don't
raids are barely enough for them and
that you it's kind of assumed you're
going to watch a video and like come
knowing what to do already so they kind
of you know it subverts that requirement
already except for people who do it
blind which like i do it blind and you
know it's good but teddy you're going to
say something before yeah so yeah i got
two things so
kind of i mean you want to sit on most
of the points that i was going to
counter from travis but destiny does
have nuance but it's just not
it's just not like
it's not the dark souls level of nuance
and
there are there are things that like as
a skilled player that you learn
from like when to pop your super or when
to when to pick up the orbs that have
been sitting there for a while or when
to use a certain gun or or amp like
maximizing your ammo for for gms and
stuff like that maybe not necessarily in
the raid um so i think there is to
counter you there is a level of like
knowledge and skill from there and and
in destiny does have
somewhat of that old nes style game of
like you learn from failure from the
hard difficulty activities but it's not
the same level because no game is ever
going to go back to that maybe dark
souls but that's that's what they're
known for that's a thing right your
failure is the experience i think it's
becoming more common i think games are
starting to go back and not be afraid to
be hard because people because you want
that fantastic people
there's a market for it for sure yes
right and then my so then my second
point is i can kind of explain why
zesting kind of feels cheesy sometimes
at least in terms of the ai so if we if
we backpedal all the way to halo 1.
one of the things that made halo 1 so
revolutionary was the ai
was so ahead of its time and the reason
for this is two things that bungie
developed i i don't think they invented
it but they definitely refined it to the
point where everyone was using this for
the next two decades yeah they created
they created behavioral trees yes so
that ai would do certain things based on
the player's positioning and what the
player was doing so the easiest example
i can give you is if you throw a grenade
into the right what was the elite do
they eat rolls yeah fifty percent of the
time and halo one two and whatever i
don't know whatever they change in later
games but effectively it's the same
thing and there's there's a myriad of
things another example is if you kill
the brute in a pack of uh a brute and
grunts or an elite the grunts will freak
out
yeah right and stuff like that and you
learn that as you play uh over time the
second thing is the ai were extremely
reactionary to
uh the actual mission structure and
scripting of the mission destiny is also
very scripted we just don't see it uh as
often because of the open world nature
and sometimes you just see enemies just
standing there they're not doing
anything so when you play like the gm
level content where everything's
one-shotting you it's because they're
reading your positioning and inputs for
certain things and that's why it feels
cheap and cheesy sometimes so then you
have to do these really dumb things like
standing all the way in the back of the
map where the snipers can't hit you or
you know you gotta you gotta nuke the
enemy before it spawns because that's
the best strategy to not deal with the
chieftains bombs or the or the
abomination or stuff like that and so i
don't i agree with you i think there
should be more nuanced mechanics or
timing mechanics or stuff like that like
like if i could parry an enemy in
destiny that would be amazing that would
be awesome but i'm that hunter jump at
the right time right yeah yeah or if i
or if i melee if i use my warlock melee
at the same time that an enemy throws
something at me you know i can bounce it
back or something i don't know something
cool like that right i mean it is
your point
i just wanted to overdo it no i just
wanted to say one thing because
you mentioned just like the mechanics of
like throwing a grenade and they dodged
and you like
why is it the higher level enemy that
you face they're all big giant weenies
that go hide all of them in destiny are
like knights like oh you and honestly
somebody was mentioning it to me and
it's like and it seems accurate and you
probably could confirm if you aim down
sights of something it moves it knows
you're doing that and as you said if
you're like grand masters like so i'm
sitting there looking down a sniper
rifle like far enough the way to barely
be able to see the stupid wizard's head
but if i look at it it moves i'm like
i'm so far well you don't even know i'm
here
and then i sit there and i go through
death loop and you're like yeah those
guys are on the other side of dumb which
is i mean that was part of the fun of
that game they're actually kind of i
think gave a little beef to that
recently but
that's one of those things like if i
pull out a weapon it's like hey you're
there and all of a sudden it's like
you're just hovering hovering okay i'm
gonna take this one shot whoosh and i'm
like i miss i'm like that's not me like
not lining up my shot that's the game
saying hey you're looking at me i'm
gonna move just because you're looking
at me
oh and that's like that takes away from
like hey let me line up the shot because
i'm in a safe piece of cover i found
this right now you're over there uh the
shrieker i took care of just a second
ago all right let me work on this
section now i look at you move and i'm
like and then you start losing ammo and
then ammo is unreliable and it's just
like compounds on another i'm like
you're going to put this in a harder
situation you know what i'm going to do
before i do it that's kind of cheap
how many times have you shot a
projectile weapon either a fusion rifle
rock launcher minotaur and a teleporter
oh my god
as as the bullet is about to oh whatever
you're saying how many times have you
done that because it knows and and it's
just it is cheesy like so to finish my
analogy or my explanation halo halo's
eye has been revolutionary for so long
and destiny cop uses anything but they
advance it by by making the ai server
side rather than right on the client
side but it's showing its age like it's
they're still doing i mean they're more
complex obviously now than they were in
the days of halo but it's just not a fun
experience for players and i think most
people don't realize that that's what's
happening but like i mean you picked it
up you learned you learned on your own
that aiming down sights causes them to
move i just do that from halo so even in
destiny 1 i was like oh if the enemies
are hiding like they always did or they
always do just donate on sites and then
they'll pop back out and i've been
telling people that for years but
they they need the ai definitely needs
an update like it's yeah gm certain gms
and certain high-level content can just
be absolutely abysmal not because it's
actually challenging but because bungie
just uses a slider to increase the i
mean this is i'm yeah yeah
oversimplifying it but that's totally so
hard
accuracy and enemy knowledge is like 10
out of 10 and you're like yeah i'm
playing chess i'm like i'm working at
checkers here and you guys are already
over two chessboards over it's like
that's not fair yeah i'm playing chess
and they're playing 40 chess
they can see me through time yeah i feel
like they know before i even make the
move um yeah well if you've ever played
chess against a uh computer that's
turned all the way up it's basically
impossible to win
yeah yep so
well the final major piece this week um
obviously festival's still going on you
got exodus crash going on in the
nightfalls which
could have fun she's in that one
but the big one coming next week is
going to be freelance trials
that is no sorry this weekend i'm sorry
it's this weekend um so in less than 24
hours saint fulton will be dabbling in
another labs weekend for trials of
osiris it is freelance basically nobody
goes in as teams
and
there is i want to kind of say before we
get into this i sent myself something uh
i think dmg posted something on twitter
or sorry reddit it looks like
says a few things
and that's between trials population and
other stuff it says it's expected that
the trials population decrease week over
week the team is doing work to see what
can be done to reduce the decline or
even increase population occasionally
but right now we're in a period of
trying new things between the rework to
rewards and trials labs every few
weekends we're getting a ton of great
data to inform potential changes to the
mode of in the future we want trials to
be the best that it can be as we want
destiny me to be the best that it can be
there will still be bumps there will be
hiccups we're excited about the
knowledge we're gaining and we could
come and what could come about in the
future number two flawless pool will be
enabled on sunday
team is cooking up
changes for trials matchmaking and will
provide additional information when we
have it i mentioned another comment it
looks like we may have it in the twab
next week but can't promise it yet with
regards to
the flawless pool is eventually
something they
do want to get rid of
it's just kind of like a band-aid for
the moment and they said in terms of
uncompetitive matches team is
investigating
uh as we introduce more labs weekends
and address feedback from previous we're
still digging through data in terms of
players are resetting at six wins it
seems that's a minuscule population of
players is actually doing that in
practice yes
yes it's an issue that needs addressed
but it's not burning down the playlist
to the extent that some are stating uh
thanks for continuing to shoot feedback
our way in discussions um while we can't
reply to every single subject in every
single twab uh these conversations were
having meetings pretty frequently just
as you guys were saying they
they're good at bringing all the
information in watching the twitter
keeping that information getting it
going to you but it's like i also wanted
to mention to you guys like whether it's
population numbers or anything like that
like it is kind of stuff that's going
down so
freelance is coming and basically the
big thing is
freelance labs is gonna be this weekend
so you're gonna have
solo players only all in there and then
i guess your
everybody's gotta
theoretically be threes because i don't
know how you're gonna do or i guess you
can go into the trials playlist as a non
as a solo player and find the one two
stack that's in there but it's probably
not gonna be great and i actually wanted
to there will be there will be two
stacks and then there will also be
people who just don't know about the
freelance playlist because what does
that button do
yeah they always make it this like tiny
notebook
which confuses me uh yeah like why not
just why not make that one the bigger
one since most people are playing solo
but
yeah so i just wanted to get your
thoughts i wanted to give it to travis
first just you know kind of where trials
has been the fact that i actually kind
of missed it when iron banner was here
was weird don't say that um
yeah no it's like iron banner was here
and i'm like that's like if you do your
iron banner bounty's like i'm kind of
good at that playlist because you know
that it's not a directed farm you can't
take the tokens and buy a certain role
like trials gets the update and we're
still waiting for an iron banner update
so then i'm kind of going
at least trials i know i can go after
certain things the armor that drops in
there has actually usually got pretty
good stats like it's actually not a bad
place to spend even time of me getting
beaten down like i jumped in on sunday
afternoon after that flawless went live
last week
and i still was facing like i know there
was a team i looked them up later they'd
been flawless like 30 times and some
reason i'm playing these people i'm like
why are you in here but
travis where yet absolutely is not great
um
yeah i so i haven't been playing a lot
of trials recently um i sort of you know
i i went flawless the first couple of
weeks that the weekends that it was
around and then afterward i was sort of
like all right well got all the armor
got all the weapons and
it it's not really a mode that i go to
for like
competition or improvement anymore uh
just because it's you know
you're either you're either facing
groups that have already gone flawless
and
like i i like i like place placing those
groups but because there's no
ranking right or skill based system or
anything like that it's sort of a it's
just the wild west right you never know
what you're gonna get you're gonna crush
some teams get crushed by other teams
and then the rare like balanced match
that's actually fun isn't really worth
that sort of effort so
i predict that
the trials playlist will probably
continue to
get smaller just because there's not a
whole lot of reason to do it and i don't
think it's unique enough a game mode
anymore to really like draw an audience
um
so i i'm sure they'll continue to work
on it
but uh yeah i'm you know it's gonna be a
lot it's gonna be a long season for you
yeah i i think i'll be vindicated in
time over the stuff i said about like
the changes they made to it um i i do
think that making a freelance playlist
is probably a good move because just
like
for people who want to play against full
stacks like myself and you're in a team
of three and then you get a team that
just has absolutely no chance because
there's like solo people playing it that
doesn't feel good so i think that that's
good for them to do it but i just think
that there are
too many changes to trials that they'd
have to do to make it the mode that i
want to play
and there's not really an alternative
for me right there's not a rocket
league-esque uh ranking system where i
can play my peers or anything like that
so i've been sort of down on on comp in
uh in destiny for a little bit but we'll
see what happens man still love the game
uh but yeah i haven't haven't really
been playing trials recently so
teddy what if that tells you anything
yeah i mean i
only played trials the first like three
weeks and basically stopped caring i got
the god world reads regret before trials
was even active because i saved a bounty
from the previous season nice oh damn
and then and then the week that it was
available which i think was week two i
got
uh a better one an adept one or whatever
that is like marginally better but i
mean trials for me is always i'm always
going to go in a group i'm not i might
actually solo it this weekend because
there's a there's a challenge that uh i
have to do and there's no way i'm going
to build a course two friends to
to go in what's the challenge
let's just win 20 rounds they did it
last season too oh yeah that's just one
of the seasonal triumphs so yeah it's
just played true
just play trouble i i i've so far
enjoyed what they've done with it i
haven't played like the
the labs weekends where they they had
like the flag or whatever
oh
yeah
there's nothing
great so that's probably okay yeah i i i
heard it wasn't it wasn't too great but
um
i don't know like
i saw someone mentioning on twitter that
they should release more stats every
week like they were initially and i
think they should do that because people
want to know that stuff and the fact
that we have to go digging for it every
time either using charlemagne or destiny
tracker stuff like that and those
numbers aren't necessarily like
perfect because they're the way they're
they're generating i mean they're
accurate but not you know bungie has the
actual numbers
um
so
stuff
i'm just i'm pretty lukewarm about it
like it's whatever it's trials um i i'm
at a point right now where i just i boot
up destiny like i said on tuesday i get
my triumphs done my challenge is done i
played for an hour two max and then i'm
i'm done like i got other stuff going on
destiny
i needed a break from destiny and i'm
not gonna go
trying to get myself an aneurism in
trials
yeah i've been um i'm probably obviously
the opposite of everyone here i've been
enjoying it i look forward to playing it
every weekend um i was bummed when iron
banner came because like damn there's no
trials this week now i miss it you know
what i'm saying but
yeah like the solo the freelancers for
me this is literally for me like i i do
not i play at weird times of night
getting people together it's sometimes
difficult again i shout out the crew
when they do grab me and scoop me up and
sometimes to be honest you know i'm i'm
late when i'm jumping in i'm i'm past
the flawless pool because i'm just so
busy you know what i'm saying prepping
for other stuff so i'll come in on a
sunday and a monday
and then it's you know it's yo it's just
super sweat flawless people central you
know i mean it's just you know so for me
i i like this this is what i do for
bannon like i'll jump in banner i'll
jump in that freelance and i like the
idea of knowing that everyone else is in
my situation
everyone so if i lose i'm like okay
those three guys are by themselves but
it's tougher when you go in there and
it's when you plan to play the solo
trials experience the way that it was
set up prior
and you have you know that you're going
to play i almost like frown when i see
two clan names or this opposite team
when you fly in and you're like on all
three of them
yeah because you like you're gonna get
crushed they're gonna be important i
mean you're not you're not what it is it
is a rare
it's so rare when you're like hey
there's three and like you're like oh we
run out and you're like do i have like a
banger on my team like what just
happened like i actually pulled a match
out and then yeah then they seem to be
like oh we got to take this serious and
then you don't seem but
it's very rare but more often than not
you see three and you're like can i just
like hit the like default forfeit button
and move on to the one that might
actually be fun
to be honest
to me when i see two
even the two with the third
like i'm like yeah if you're all so
close it's still gonna be yeah because
they're coordinated
yeah because you know what i get mad i'm
like how come i'm never the third
random with the two claps it's aware if
you do get that that actually happened
to me
there was that guy well that actually
happened to me and they actually sent me
an invite and i ended up playing with
them playing with them right yeah yeah
you're like
yeah because they were like hey you kind
of held your own basically they were
like we needed a third who basically
wasn't complete trash and i was like a
potato that's me i'm not a potato i have
a potato and working arms that's it
small upgrade but i was like i was able
to do okay and they're like hey we just
need somebody that can help kind of roll
us out so that they actually invited me
to their team i was like you know i
would at least like type chat which does
help if you're not on console because at
least i can type
but yeah it's like for me it's
it's the solo will be nice because i
know everyone will be so low as like and
at least in those matches there are
times
for my
mediocre average person it's like the
ones where it's like i know you're
saying some are sweaty some are not
the ones that are sweaty and it's like
it's four to five and i'm like that was
actually a fun match even if it's at
like a low skill level those are fun
it's bummed when i lose the four to five
it's like we almost pulled it back but
we didn't quite get there but there was
like there was fight we're kind of going
yes that actually so i was like
that's why i want to play this weekend
my brother's going to be here this
weekend he actually wanted to try and
jump on the podcast
he's at a wedding in fort worth instead
of dallas and he was like when's the
podcast and i was like it's tonight
so yeah he's going to be at my house
tomorrow so he'll be around for the
weekend shut up don't be stoned tell us
something yeah i like still yeah like i
wish i said i want to try this board i
want to see what it is i think the
bigger issue to me
when we're looking at population stuff
and all that i don't i think a lot of
stuff is overblown as far as the
not as far as like i don't want the the
stuff travis to talk about i do want
that i do want that that skill gap thing
i mean skill ranking thing but what i'm
what i feel is
the real issue again it goes back to
what we said earlier is always going to
be incentive right because at the end of
the day
once you get your god roll reads i mean
teddy already had his before he even got
in but the thing is not teddy's not a
pvp player he's always going to need
incentive to get into the mode i
honestly think like if you if you made
trials feel good if you implemented a
even i disagree because even if you feel
even if you have that we just
established if the rewards are not worth
it you're it's about how good it feel if
you if you go in there and you get in
the same crappy guns that been existing
from two trials before it doesn't matter
we've already established
that if the rewards are not good it
doesn't matter how great something is
its people are not are gonna drop off
and the only thing that they had this
season was a stasis linear fusion rifle
that nobody seen before and it had
firing line and vorpal and you're like
yo i need that once you got that you
already had igneous you already have
messenger you already had to eat you're
not going in there for no almond you
definitely ain't going in there for no
celebrity
i think i think that's a certain type of
player that only wants to go in but
those are like edge cases who maybe
don't want to play pvp to me
they're
they're getting lured in right like
honestly if i felt like nine out of 10
matches in trials i was going to be
playing people that were at my skill
level and having close matches and i was
having fun i would not care what the
reward is to be honest you represent a
very small percentage if you if you play
a lot of people say yo what are we
playing this for for yay the sense of
competition or yo you're gonna get a hot
gun i guarantee if we run that poll the
gun people gonna win
i mean it's called competitive for a
reason right like the idea is that
you're playing but that's the thing like
why do people why do people play halo
but that's a different one
there's no loot in exotics in halo
that's something exactly you can't make
that right but but you can't make that
comparison this is only i can't because
i'm i'm using it to make your to make my
point for me which is that if the
multiplayer is good people don't care
about loot people don't care about when
they play halo because the multiplayer
is good it's not a lunar shooter it's
not it's not the same it's not the same
destiny's not a looter shooter when
you're playing pvp either you're not
there's
rewards in pvp there's pinnacle rewards
there's competitive roars there's exotic
it's not the same you cannot put what
halo is doing and one to one at
competitive destiny they're not the same
game
i'm saying people people play parts of
the game for different reasons that's
right and i i think pvp is where you
take your loot and you put it to the
test
okay not necessarily a place where you
need to be earning loot i say of course
if you're earning loot that's a plus and
it'll draw in certain players but the
majority of players in destiny play for
luke travis you can't escape that you
keep trying to act like that's a minimum
thing you play this game for loot that's
it
for no you don't the majority of people
are not just playing it for the love of
the game that is not a destiny player i
think i think destiny pvp players they
play pve for the loot they play pvp to
put their loot to the test and i think
that if you if they if the experience
was in equal matches where they were
really competitive and you were getting
to put your skills and the weapons and
they get no good gun
all i'm saying all i'm saying cog is the
reward would matter a lot a lot less and
now it matters a ton because the game
doesn't feel good and that's why the
teddy's oh the world log off and it's
why i log off like i'm not even playing
it because even honestly cog even if
there was good loot and there has been
good loot in the past i wouldn't play
because the trial is experienced but
again yeah you represent the small
percentage that you should you refuse to
acknowledge that you are you are the
smaller as you said you are not the
major you do not represent the majority
of destiny pvp players you don't but you
keep over conflating your opinion as if
you represent the majority you don't
think i'm sorry you don't i think you're
overstating
more than it's ever been played so the
stats are still in my favor even with a
decline they're in my favor in your
favor they didn't exist
they didn't exist
of course when you lower barriers and
you say hey there's a new thing people
are going to flood in the test of time
is will it maintain that and or will it
go down because people aren't having fun
and i think i will be vindicated i think
over time
there's nothing to be vindicated with at
the end of the day it's people playing
versus people
maybe so then i could say the same
excuse before trials wasn't working
because everybody just had their loot
and didn't care about new loot like it
you know what i'm saying like it does
you really want to compare the numbers
of trials now versus trials
we don't know the numbers because
they're not telling us right but so you
think they you think they were you
thinking teddy you all right over there
i i i ain't touching this one
listen i love travis but it's like i i
hate the fact that
because of how he feels he thinks that
represents the majority and i completely
disagree he does not represent the
majority of pvp players in destiny
because because he's not playing because
he doesn't have the ranking system does
not mean the majority of people in
destiny are not having fun still playing
the music and they got numbers does it
sound crazy to you cog that i think that
the reason most people play pvp is to
have fun and not necessarily for the
kids of course but it's not acting like
you're acting like the game is not fun
at all that's the part
the imbalanced matchmaking experience
where you don't know if you're gonna go
up against somebody who's super powerful
or somebody that you're just gonna crush
is an inherently not fun and not healthy
experience for pvp and if they could
just fix that and make the pvp mode good
in and of itself the loot would matter
less
it would be more about people would play
destiny for the reason they play halo
for the reason to play rocket league not
for the loot but for the experience i'm
gonna say something
hold on okay last point last point and i
swear i'll stop
the point i'm trying to say is
in a perfect world right everything he's
saying with our ideal situations that we
all want this is still a mole
why are you dying on a hill where you
don't give him like one grain of salt
for me yeah
all i'm saying is i feel this is my
opinion that because he is not happy
with the mode
he feels that represents the majority of
players and that at his his point will
be proven because no one everyone else
kind of feels that it's not a fun mode
all i'm saying is they are continually
tweaking and trying to get things right
while enjoying the best numbers they've
had in the mode since
baby d1 so to me it's still a success
that's not a failure to me that's not
something that everyone's looking at it
like yo oh my god this is so bad i'm not
playing anymore there's still a bunch of
issues that still have to be fixed
that's what i'm saying i'm done you
could tell i got you and all i'm saying
is that if the only reason the player
base is high is because they want the
rewards and they're not having fun
during the experience i have a problem
with that and i'm not saying that that
the the only reason why they do it what
the issue was it was so inaccessible and
people were getting crushed people were
getting i agree that's bad i don't want
that to be the case
i think both so they're more issues
right experiences are bad i think both
of them are bad so we okay we agree we
fix this yes
you guys got there on your own this is
just beautiful
i totally have strong opinions
i want destiny pvp to be no and all i
wanted to say yeah
i want i want my friends to play the
mode i'm tired of nobody wants to play
trial i'm tired of it i i hate that's my
favorite mode in destiny i love this
thing so much i'm going to
you realize you realize my solution
actually makes the mode more accessible
than it is right now
if you put no no because look if you put
ranked systems the images of the world
are going up against the other ebonitis
so they're still having a competitive
match but he would be way more likely to
go flawless if he's in a ranked system
maybe he's at bronze three you know
offensively yeah but maybe urban's three
but it actually makes it more accessible
and it makes people like me who want to
play at my level which might be higher
it also gives us what we want so like i
just i just don't see how my solution is
bad at all no okay i want to say okay
i don't disagree i don't disagree with
that okay i want to say something one
diwar is in chat says how many people
jumped off a cliff when there was an
igneous hammer versus a less desirable
gun
that leads very much into what kag is
saying but loot is very important but on
the other side i agree because it's not
hold on i'm not done
how long on the other side when pvp
actually does feel good
helped keep destiny alive just because
people enjoyed the activity of destiny
pvp so it's both of those that's why
i was listening to both of you i'm like
you're both right you're just like
arguing for no reason so it's like no
but
don't don't act like he my thing was
getting he's mad get me mad don't act
like his weight is the only way to be
fixed that's what was getting on my
nerve like i'm acknowledging his way
like my way was i wasn't saying that
dude i really wasn't saying that that's
all yeah that's all that's probably how
i feel promise you i wasn't saying that
congratulations okay and that's how i
felt so i apologize because i thought
that's how you felt no i i really don't
yeah it's like basically i want the loot
to be good i just don't want the loot to
be the only reason people play the mode
right now
crucible is a fun if crucible is a fun
experience matchmaker is decent you have
good matches like my four versus fives
it's one of those things you'll play
because like i don't have a whole lot
going on i'm gonna go play crucible or
i'm gonna go play trials because hey
this could be fun for a little while
even though i don't need the loot is
there a reason to go for the pinnacles
to go after the ignis to go for the
readings regret absolutely and those
need there the ranking system a reason
to go to the top of that leaderboard
does need to be there because the carrot
needs to still be on the stick but also
as travis is saying if pvp sits in a
good place and i go into matches and i'm
having fun if weapons feel relatively
balanced which we worry is never gonna
be there but it's like if the mode feels
decent
that's gonna just give again destiny
another leg to stand on as opposed to
when it is just pvp so it's like you
guys were yelling and i was just like
kind of letting it go but that's why i
wanted to stop it because in you're both
right like the mode should be fun on its
own as travis is saying even if the loot
is
less important you have a good time in
there is good but also is cog saying
loot is important people jumped off a
cliff for an igneous hamburger so we
need both like that's i agree that's all
i'm saying i'm just waiting
i think we're totally teddy before we
like wrap this thing up because we are
getting a long one of course you're on
here for a long show
do you have any dog in this fight at
this point or at least an opinion
uh the only thing i'll say is it's kind
of
sort of to travis's point right i guess
cogs point
they have been trying to make the
matches more competitive and they even
mentioned that this week in the twab
they're trying to minimize the the one
fives or the zero five matches because
they want that experience more
competitive and there absolutely is a
level of spm that's going on
in the background um so i i don't i
don't know
or is it is it
we've talked about this before i don't
know yeah we're talking about am i yeah
yeah i mean i i agree there should be
some rankings of some but i think
destiny's just like they're dealing with
other problems like they're they're
they're fine tuning it
so that down the line
they can think of this like i said this
last time i was a podcast i think all
these trials changes are just one big
experiment for them to gather all this
data so that come witch queen and during
the year of which queen they can really
really hone in trials because i think
trials has to evolve i think the 2015
trials doesn't doesn't work like it just
doesn't and um
to cog's point i i
i agree like i from i think for the most
people you need an incentive to go into
the mode and play there are the travis
of the world that are like i just want
to play for the rank because i want a
competitive experience and the reward
comes second but destiny is first and
foremost has always been a looter
shooter and you do everything because
the reward is the thing that is like
you're chasing the carrot that's that's
like the point of the game um i'm not
saying everyone is like that but that's
just that's just how it is
i i think the carrot is to get you to
play the motor to try the mode or
whatever but if you fall in love with
the mode while you're playing it and
then you're just playing it just for the
sake of it then you get a situation like
why people play halo while people play
rocket league which is not all about uh
the reward it's about just you do it
because it's it's that's the means to
the end and i i just want i want destiny
to be more like that like it's basically
the same point i made for pve which is
like why are you suffering through
grandmaster nightfalls just to get a box
with some loot at the end shouldn't you
be playing a game mode that you actually
like
and also get some loot from it and that
it's it's my problem with pve and it's
my problem with pvp the end game and
destiny is just in a really bad place
aside from raids and dungeons everything
else that they've tried with endgame has
just not worked the difference between
those multiplayer games that you
mentioned and destiny is that the
progression is different in both games
in those multiplayer games you're
progressing a rank and that's all you're
progressing maybe cosmetics but in
destiny the progression isn't a rank it
can be but it's usually yeah it yeah but
it's more usually your arm or your
weapons and so the the
the primary thing you are chasing
to ascertain is not
they're the difference so i think the
comparison isn't uh but i mean also like
okay
the primary thing that you're going
after is the loot yes but if there was a
secondary thing to go with it it gives
you reason to extend the life of and so
like that's of course that's again what
you're going for is like you have to
lose the primary thing try this thing
it's fun
secondary is the rank hey my rank moved
up a little bit okay well now this will
be kind of a thing you do that's what
yeah that's what i think you're getting
that travis you wanna hand and extension
of it ranked systems ranked systems also
have loot associated with them in pretty
much every game so like in hearthstone
if you reach like diamond tier there's a
whole list of here's the rewards you get
at the end of the season if you manage
to get to this tier and so you can also
attach
uh rewards and loot to like ranking up
that system and i in my mind that's just
like that's got to be part of adding a
ranked system is i have to have a reason
to want to progress from silver to gold
over the course of a season and get
better because the the rewards that i
get at the end of that season if i reach
that tier are
higher and then at the end of the season
everybody goes back to unranked and they
have to like re-earn and find their
place on the ladder i just think that
that sort of system would solve a lot of
the like problems with
imbalance in matchmaking and imbalance
and trials and getting those lopsided
matches and it would give people like a
a sort of another bar to chase right
like a a way to level up so
my final my final point i want to say is
um the reason why i say
we have to be careful with saying that
it's no reason to go in there right now
because it's not fun when i see the
community
how excited they get because to me i
think this is my bigger point
i think
mercury's when we had him on set at best
there's a subset of people who are the
best people in pvp right
and those guys are always going to
aspire and those guys are going to be
great but i think
when there's the hope
that you can actually go right to go
flawless that you can actually go that
when people are not completely destroyed
and i agree that
the matchmaking is still not perfect of
course but the fact that there is hope
now to incentivize people to try the
mold to get in the mold you know i think
that to me is the overall grade of good
which comes into the accessibility
augment right right what we have
better than what we had for sure
my point is my point is that a ranked
system would make it better for everyone
it would make it better for the mercury
i agree and i'm not disagreeing with a
ranked system i've never once said hey i
don't want a ranked system hey i don't
like it all i'm saying is i just look at
the overall greater good for the
community i don't think about just my
personal need i think about every little
johnny who was who got destroyed every
round one that he jumped in
every round went and when you got a guy
like ibontis who would never
play never yeah
and he's like yo i kind of missed it i'm
a bit of a masochist though because when
i did jump in last weekend and when the
matchmaking doesn't hit right it sucked
until i found those two points
matchmaking doesn't hit right i was like
and i was like i was
yeah i didn't have anything to do you
know throw on like something in the
background and i'm kind of like halfway
going through because i keep seeing
three stack and three stack and three
stacks so it's like i'm looking for a
little of that but it's like yeah you
guys
you're you're both good you're like i
get where you guys are both at we don't
need to kill it anymore like we both
want this thing to evolve and get better
and give you know a lot of different
levels of people a reason to go in
whether it is the fun of the mode the
loot a combination of both i think
that's a good thing
to get there yeah yeah except
accessibility one more thing which is
like rankings
and then rewards it's a trifecta it's a
it's a thing yeah one more thing that i
it's like a separate point from
everything else we've talked about which
is that when when when i make my points
people try to put me on the opposite
side of accessibility that like i'm an
elitist and that i want this experience
that's like premium and only accessible
to certain classes and that's just not
true at all like i'm not at the same
skill level as mercury's i don't want to
like match mercury's i just want to
match people who are in my skill range
that's not anti-accessibility i'm not
some [ __ ] like sorry i'm not some
like god who's like at the top pinnacle
i you know i used to be really good at
destiny pvp but i haven't been that in
years because i play other games now
because i have to for ign reviews and
stuff i just don't have the time to be
competitive in destiny anymore but i
think it would be beneficial to the
entire community if there was a system
that bucketed people with their peers
and gave us a reason to actually try to
get better because right now part of the
reason i don't play as
as often as i used to in competitive is
because i don't feel like i'm going to
be able to sharpen my skills by playing
against this super lopsided matchmaking
system that doesn't make sense to me and
i just think that that's a real problem
so yeah
i
it's like that's not the case at all
i think teddy said it best i totally
understand i think what teddy said it
best was
this is still a process for them right
this is the tweaking
to which queen's eventual version of
trials and i think the data
you know this week is is the freelance
this week it's they've always been so
data heavy and and hopefully the hope is
when that which queen joint comes out we
get the accessibility within our
matchmaking right we get the proper
reward such section where it's flushed
out where it's a lot you know armor
there's different web not just one
little weapon and that's it go away yeah
right and then we get the travis which
is we yo
check this out remember how comp was and
you had the thing now everyone in legend
tier and heroic
in the beginning whatever tier you're at
your matchmaking you're more likely to
always match make against those guys so
this way you're playing people of the
same level you get those those three to
fours those five to fours you know what
i'm saying danny i bro i'm with you
don't think i'm not with you on that
like i am there and i think it's just
weird
i think i think this is
not needed argument but that's fine
i just feel like uh we've talked about
it on the show a ton of times and i've
i've never felt like i
like that
yeah i got people to understand what i'm
talking about i'm not trying to create
like an elitist paradise i got you i
just want i just want there to be a
place for competitive and where the mode
can feel a little bit better than it
does today because because personally my
experience the reason cog i'm really
glad that you're having fun at trials
but like i'm not like when i play trials
now and not to say that i was having
much more fun before when it was like
right filled with cheaters and like and
all that stuff that was a huge hurdle
that was a huge huge hurdle obviously
but i'm just saying that like right now
my experience with it is that 90 percent
of the time probably more we just
destroy their team and i'm done on the
first ticket and then i log off because
i'm just not really having fun yeah yeah
yeah you do
i don't want to ruin everybody's day by
just destroying them right but then i
also don't want to get up against the
team that's way outside of my skill
level and i don't know it's just it's
it's so few and far between when i play
a a match and to teddy's point they they
clearly care about that and they're
working on it i just don't see anywhere
in what they're saying that they have
any sort of plan to actually build out a
system that
is better than this is our best guess
because teddy and i have talked about
this for a long time it seems like
they're doing it based off of play time
how often you play crucible which is not
a good metric for matching again
that's why he gets screwed over because
he's play he plays a lot more than the
average player and his skill level isn't
at the same level of people who are
playing all the time and and then you
know i get probably on the opposite end
because i tend to go up against people
who are not very good because my play
time is lower these days again and then
you know i'm just so it just it just
isn't a good situation i i think that
they're
i don't think which queen will be the
time they fix this i think if they fix
it it'll be down the road because i just
think they're way behind the hope is
that they get there at some point last
time i hope they get their if they could
get there by witch queen i would be
flabbergasted but i just don't think
it's going to happen befuddled you could
say any other fun words you can throw
out there
the smirched no that's merch
[Laughter]
well this is probably a good place to
wrap it up as shockingly when teddy's
here we get a little long in the tooth
but that is okay sir
um
i want to thank you for jumping on kind
of last minute with us i know literally
just reached out today but i was like
you want to and i hope you joined us i
feel like you were kind of staring at
these two
go at it a little bit for there for a
little while but i'm hopefully you
enjoyed joining us but kind of as usual
the floor is yours let people know where
to find you if you're like hey i threw
content in here or whatever it is you're
doing what you're working on or just if
you got a cool project you're working on
on your own just tell people what you're
doing
yeah so uh first of all thank you for
coming to my ted talk where we uh
we aired our grievances and uh have our
guardian therapy for the week yep that's
that's what this is i said it at the
beginning and uh i didn't expect that to
happen but it worked out i guess in our
favor
so yeah thanks thanks for having me it's
always it's always fun to do these and
and chat with the family and you already
know often we'll talk about destiny um
actually i'm gonna promote something i
worked on recently which is something
nice so uh
i i helped uh this is a very
collaborative project so i'm not gonna
take all the credit for it i did a very
small part
um we did the top 10 n64 games which if
you know ign's history is actually very
uh
important to ign's history because
engine was founded on the same day the
n64 came out yes um so they redid the
list and all this stuff and i i did a
bunch of the capture for the n64 games
not all of it but the vast majority of
it and i i got some really cool tech
behind the scenes that made it look
really extra crispy and just perfect no
one's gonna know any of that but like it
just it felt like you do that's what's
important
it looked
hdn64 on real hardware yeah
what were what are the top three end up
as or can you say yeah yeah yeah okay
[Applause]
okay
i'm always torn on like three because
those are always two high ones perfect
dark maybe maybe goldeneye gold and i
got which ones that would be favored if
it's up there at least by like enjoyment
now it looks like trash but who knows
just go look at the door of the list
okay yep go to the ign top 10 n64 update
sound uh
pocket time isn't number one we we
protest
mark medina put his thumb on the scale
because he would just say mario 64 no
matter what you know granted mark i 100
of both of those but still yeah
oh yeah so good
so yeah uh i think you bought this as in
the video teasing teddy is my twitter
i'm usually just uh either trolling
these fine gentlemen or one of my
co-workers and i don't take twitter
seriously so if you if you take it
seriously then i'm sorry that you
that you found me
taking twitter seriously yeah they do i
mean some people did today
go look at the reply of mine man that
was
i literally applied to i have replied to
uh dmg later and i was like i'm sorry to
have started the twitter fire is like
yeah thanks for bringing the bug to our
attention
yeah travis what about you here so go
ahead yeah uh i recently reviewed uh a
game called the rift breaker it's a uh
rts base builder with twin stick bullet
hell stuff in it the review went live uh
earlier today i think it was like it's a
it's a very great good game that is
so complicated it will give you
nightmares so if that sounds like
a uh a fun experience to you i recommend
it it's on game pass actually
i gave it an 8 out of 10. you can read
that on ign.com
and then i'm i'm also reviewing uh
writer's republic which my review will
probably be live next week i hope i mean
we'll see how long of a game it is i
haven't started it yet i'm gonna do that
right after this
um and then um yeah you can read my
reviews previews articles on ign.com you
can follow me on twitter at tie guy
travis you can watch me fight with cog
every thursday every thursday pacific
every thursday we just start duking it
out um we have makeup sex afterwards
though
and then um
and then you can also watch me on
sundays at 8 am pacific on a show called
big cast um which is a kind of like a
general gaming show with my friend shout
out to you shout out to your father's
dear raj yeah my friend aims and a
homeless wizard that wanders on the set
each week um so we we have uh we have
good times together
that's me how about you cog where can we
find you i'm clipping down i'm sitting
you'll be going himself i told you like
i come up with a new disrespectful way
to describe him every week on the show
tremendous show shout out to teddy
falling out man always a pleasure the
the calming influence to the wild this
track
signal yes yes i'm secretly always just
angry inside
welcome to my ted talk on the inside
yeah on the outside i'm smooth
yeah i by apologies to your comment boys
i know they go come for me i apologize
early but you know it gets kind of good
it's gonna be fun
as uh g.k bell said um no or was it uh
and it was new ready he's like the the
youtube comments will be the true show
afterwards
please understand youtube comment boys
that it comes from a place of love you
you don't get passionate discussion
unless you love something we all love
this game
they've already written the comment
they're not listening this far
i also don't argue with people i don't
respect just exactly
i'm the same way i ignore you i'm just
saying all right believe whatever you
want right but that's why
i respect trav man i love him he's
passionate he's not he's fearless in
what he believes and he's willing to
stand on and i'm the same way we share
that so it's just it's cool to still do
these type of discussions and still be
respectful and not get crazy you know
what i'm saying at the end of the day
with a disrespectful personal attacks
that's the beauty of discussion and
people i think sometimes within this
community everyone's afraid to kind of
step on and i like that about it he's
like no no i disagree
that's what it's about man just being
respectful we got we're passionate we
love this game bungie i had to get this
work today because we had to talk about
y'all
and i'll pause that person we still love
y'all but we just had to talk about
y'all but anyway laura cognito
with each other egg bunji not telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear that's what we're about so
um yeah check us out lord cognito is
podcast sunday we'll be rocking with us
chris grinnell of uh actually that from
the gorilla games day did f1 did the
wipeout so on sony liverpool days we're
gonna be catching up with him so he'll
be in the realm on sunday we'll check
that out i'm gonna have to keep the
dominus maximus in check over there for
a sony sony guess oh boy
that was the homie like that's literally
the whole thing like he's so cool he's
about king's foolishness he'll he'll
tweak him you know he'll mess with him
stuff like that so it'll be fun check
him out we'll do his history um defining
dukes up there man speaking of heart to
hearts we had to talk about um there's
an ultimate up right now we had to talk
about what's going on with messaging as
far as uh xbox and mixed messaging and
false expectations about what games are
going to be happening and so check that
out that's a great one and then we just
did the the regular duke that's up now
and we'll be free on sunday if you guys
want to wait don't do the patreon join
and uh of course lawyersgaming.net
please check that out and there's this
podcast this last word that he doesn't
like me promoting live but i'm gonna
promote it anyway but okay i'm gonna
stop you right here because the only
reason i have a problem with this is if
they made it to the end of this
three-hour show
you're not promoting it to anybody who
doesn't already make it this far into
the show
what if they click the video end of the
show because you know you're speaking to
the loyalists you say tell your friends
see that i would be about be like tell
your friends to come check us out
not yeah hey this is the show that's
like that's always like hey this is the
great show [ __ ] just throw that in
during your promotion then i'm totally
fine with it it's a loophole
let me let me write it what's the
company line we gotta say what we gotta
say what's the company line now i gotta
say friends tell your friends hit the
like button what else we say subscribe
leave us a review on on itunes leave us
all on itunes
that's gonna be the new caveat e what's
going on with juventus
real quick sorry uh shout out to your uh
chat with ryan mccaffrey uh i i i think
yes
definitely duke i forgot the show and
your coast uh yeah maddie played really
good that's really good thank you well
yeah matt ryan he's a legend man it was
so humbling to have him on and
the beginning of that couldn't have been
better oh the beginning of that he got
you guys so i was like oh man need
like straight out the gate done
he's like how you gonna be duke saying
nobody here gotta do control i was like
damn we gotta
check water that's amazing
we gotta take the l and move on there's
nothing you can do with that like he was
right
i haven't looked it up on ebay it's 30
go buy one
sir
did you buy one or did you find one oh
yeah he probably already got one
sir
[Laughter]
you changed it right after when you were
done with that episode you bought it
didn't you oh we corrected that
how is he going to bring up the bigger
duke
let's go the bigger duke battle the
biggest back biggest baddest duke
oh we go we going left you talking about
sponsors with us
you out here compared duke compared
anyway for me you guys know i got family
in town for a little bit um
probably gonna watch dune of course
okay travis that was a good one my only
fans would be cheetah print but yeah
unfortunately you'll never find cheetah
print because it's always going to be
leopard print so therefore you're never
going to find it
actually uh but for me you're gonna make
it a thing
uh you guys know me i'm still gonna be
playing destiny making guides there
playing some new world as soon as my
monitor comes in it's gonna open up
probably my backlog to games that i want
to play in high resolution so that's
gonna be third monitor 4k 144 so i can
go finally see mostly 4k for all the
console stuff and then see some pretty
things coming from there um so that's
going to open some things up for me
those i'll probably stream on twitch
still trying to figure out the streaming
on youtube for other times so i don't
kill the videos that i do upload but
thank you guys if you do want to support
me directly patreon join this channel as
a member find me follow me but also not
just me find follow like subscribe go be
a last stand media member do all of
those things to support all of these
awesome gentlemen uh if you go to ign
refresh it like a hundred times on that
riff breaker review i'm telling you bump
those numbers up these retweets
i don't care for some reason like man it
seemed like there was a weird bug we got
like 20 000 put a bot on that review i
don't care just like
give it all the love that you guys can
if you can write a script do it whatever
it is
no it's been there forever or it's been
there for a while and there's not much
to it it's just if somebody wants to
support direct for some of you guys that
do and don't know the more
the more you find those little off
places to support somebody the more the
creator actually gets so like twitch is
50 youtube's about 70
patreon is about 90 so depending on
where your money goes is how much you
actually support the people you actually
like to follow so whether it's anybody
check that stuff out
but for this episode and the chaotic
mess that i kind of expected it would be
but i didn't did not expect it to be the
end discussion about trials to be the
spicy piece
but i guess i should have known better
you should have known
him
the whole time i also was surprised by
this i was actually gonna
when we got to the segment i was gonna
be like i'm officially done talking
about trials i've given all my opinions
and not comments on it and i
i
couldn't
resist
fell into it again as usual
yeah i was like as well the seinfeld the
show about nothing
or at least the show about things that
don't matter um for this episode you
guys have been amazing great turnout
tonight thank you guys all drop a like
again you know the reviews things help
us out so if you guys are here this long
feel free to support us all but thank
you guys for episode number 170 30 to go
to 200 so you can count them down
uh but thank you all very much for this
episode it has been
the last word